attól az embertől, aki éjjel nem tudott
pihenni, nem tudta kialudni magát,
reggel nehezen indul, akkor attól az
embertől hogyan várjuk el azt, hogy
gyakorlatilag csúcsteljesítményt tudjon
leadni, úgy fizikálisan vagy akár
mentálisan? Ez már egy elképzelhetetlen
dolog. Itt jön be az, hogy akkor
próbálja ezt a következő napját
valamivel kompenzálni, például azzal,
hogy megiszik hat kávét egy nap, amit
egész nap folytat, ami már kihatása lesz
a következő éjszakai alvás minőségére
is. És akkor belekerültünk megint ebbe
az ördöki spirálba, hogy ez akkor megint
a következő nap is rosszul fog aludni,
következő nap is hat-nyolc kávét fog
meginni, következő nap is inger
lékenyebb, nem tud fókuszálni, és akkor
ez így megy éveken vagy akár évtizedeken
keresztül.
Üdvözlök minden kedves hallgatót. A mai
epizód egy iszonyatosan izgalmas epizód.
A vendégem Botri Chsil, aki dietetikus
és alkalmazott táplálkodás tudományi
szakember. Az az igazság, hogy az elmúlt
fél órában már elkezdtünk beszélgetni,
és eszméletlenül izgalmas a téma.
Ugyanis arról fogunk beszélni, hogy egy
átlagos, középkorú, irodai munkát végző
ember hogyan tudja az energiaszintjét
maximalizálni. Üdvözlek. Üdvözöllek
Ricsi az epizódunkban.
>> Köszönöm szépen, hogy itt lehetek.
>> A téma azért jött fel bennem, mert van
egy nagyon jó könyv, a az atomi
szokások. Ezt ajánlom mindenkinek a
figyelmébe. És ott leír egy konkrét
esetet. Ez a brit kerékpáros csapatnak a
az esete volt. Általában a brit
kerékpáros csapat nagyon közepesen
teljesített. És valami történt a 2000-es
évek elején, amikor átvette egy új edző,
ez a Dave Brailsford
nevű személy, aki azt az elvet vallotta,
hogy vizsgáljuk meg az apró aspektusait
a kerékpárnak, hogy hogy mi mi is
történik ilyenkor, hogy hogy
amikor felül valaki a kerékpárra az
aerodinamikától kezdve egészen a
nyeregig, vagy a ruházatig, az étrendig,
és írt egy nagy listát több 10 vagy több
100 aspektusról, és az volt az elve,
hogyha mindegyiken egy kicsit egy
százaléknyit javít, akkor ezek nem
összeadódnak, hanem összeszorzódnak ezek
a javulások, és eszméletlen eredményeket
fognak tudni majd elérni. És a
meglepetés az, hogy ez is történt. Tehát
a 2008-ban és 12-ben megnyerték az
olimpiát és a a Tour de Franceot és
érmek hadát hozták el. És van mögötte
egy mély bölcsesség, mégpedig az, hogy
az ugyan ahogy a mi életünknek is van
rengeteg aspektussal kezdve az alvástól
egészen az étrendig, a
az információbevitelig és és rengeteg
más aspektusa. Hogyha ezeken az
aspektusokon egy kicsit tudunk
változtatni, valójában a az
energiaszintünk drasztikusan megnőhet.
És arra gondoltam, hogy egyet
beszélgethetnénk erről. Most az elmúlt
fél óra tényleg eszméletlenül izgalmas
volt, úgyhogy én bele is mennék, hogy
hogy maximalizálni tudjuk azt az időt,
amikor erről van szó.
Az első kérdésem az, hogy neked mi a
tapasztalatod szakemberként? Így, ahogy
látod a a hozzánk hasonló középkorú
embereket, akiknek már egy-két- három
gyermekük van, akik rendszeresen
küzdenek, tegyük fel azzal, hogy nehezen
ébrednek fel, nehezen indul el a napjuk,
egész nap nehezen fókuszálnak, estére
már ki vannak csavarva, ne kevés a
türelmük, és akkor persze ez egy ilyen
lefele vezető spirál, mert beszólok a
feleségemnek, akkor
lelkiismeretfordulásom van, a
lelkiismeretfordulásomra tegyük fel,
pont étkezéssel próbálom azt enyhíteni,
akkor valami csokit megeszek, felviszi a
vércokorszintemet, utána leesik a
vércukor szintem. Szóval ez egy ilyen
ördöki spirál, hogy az első kérdésem az,
hogy neked mi a tapasztalatod, hogy ez
tényleg probléma-e, vagy pedig csak
nálam probléma, tehát én kell küzdjek
vele,
>> valamint, hogy ha probléma, akkor miért
probléma ez számunkra?
>> Mindenképpen probléma. És így, ahogy te
is mondtad, hogy ebben a korosztályban,
ebben a középkorosztályban, akiknek már
van kisgyerekük, ott elképzelhető az,
hogy az elmúlt néhány évben az
alvásminőség az jelentősen romlott.
Többszöri éjszakai felkelések, többszöri
mikroébredések, ami mindenképpen kihat.
És de ez nem egy néhány napon keresztül
tartott, hanem néhány éven keresztül
fennállhat ez a probléma. Úgyhogy én
mindenképpen azzal azt javaslom, hogy
azzal kezdjék el orvosulni, hogy
rendszerezzék az alvásokat, és próbálnak
meg olyan technikákat alkalmazni, amivel
tudják az alvásminőséget javítani. Tehát
én napi szinten rengeteg emberrel
konzultálok és rengeteg emberrel
találkozok, és mindig meg szoktam
kérdezni azt, hogy hogyan alszik, reggel
pihenten, ébred-e, ki van-e száradva a
szája, hogyan tud fókuszálni, reggel
van-e energiaszintje, vagy éppen estére
lesz neki jobb az energiaszintje,
hogyan lélegzik Horkolle és éjszaka?
Tehát ilyen ilyen aprólékos kérdéseket
szoktam feltenni. És az érdekesség az,
hogy 10-ből heten, nyolcan azt
válaszolják, hogy nem alasszanak jól.
Tehát rossz az alvásminőségük, és reggel
nehezen megy miatt az ébredés. És akkor
ne attól az embertől, aki éjjel nem
tudott pihenni, nem tudta kialudni
magát, reggel nehezen indul, akkor attól
az embertől hogyan várjuk el azt, hogy
gyakorlatilag csúcsteljesítményt tudjon
leadni úgy fizikálisan, vagy akár
mentálisan? Ez már egy elképzelhetetlen
dolog. Itt jön be az, hogy akkor
próbálja ezt a következő napját
valamivel kompenzálni, például azzal,
hogy megiszik hat kávét egy nap, amit
egész nap folytat, ami már kihatása lesz
a következő éjszakai alvás minőségére
is. És akkor belekerültünk megint ebbe
az ördöki spirálba, hogy ez akkor megint
a következő nap is rosszul fog aludni,
következő nap is hat-nyolc kávét fog
meginni, következő nap is
ingerlékenyebb, nem tud fókuszálni, és
akkor ez így megy éveken vagy akár
évtizedeken keresztül. Jól van, hát
akkor jöjjön egy leltár. Az az a tervem
erre az epizódra, hogy sorra vesszük
ezeket az aspektusokat és ezt a
fragmentált tudást, amit így innen-onnan
össze lehet szedni, talán ez az epizód
most egy kicsit jobban össze fogja
fogni. És így, ahogy beszéltünk, az
alvásról kezdjük, akkor az alvással
járjuk egy picit körbe ezt, mert
őszintén szólva 20-as éveim elején nekem
eszembe nem jutott, hogy én gondolkozzak
az alvás minőségemen. És amikor a
gyerekek megszülettek, nem volt időm
gondolkozni. Egyszerűen az volt, hogy
sodródtam az árral. Tehát, hogy amíg
kicsik a gyerekek, az egy trauma is
egyszerre a családnak, hogy hogy
hirtelen beleszületett egy új élet a
családunkba, és valójában meghalunk és
újjászületünk. Tehát, hogy annyira nem
gondolkoztam így az alvásminőségen,
főleg az első két gyermeknél.
Viszont az elmúlt két évben kezdtem el
hallani ezekről és utána járni. Nagyon
kíváncsi vagyok, én is jegyzetelek. egy
pár dolgot érteni vélek az alvással
kapcsolatban, de járjuk körbe ezt a
témát. Mitől alszik jól egy ember?
A jó alvásnak az az alapja, hogy
legyenek meg megfelelően a menjenek
végbe megfelelően az alvási ciklusok, az
alvási szakaszok. És ezen belül is a
legfontosabb az, tehát am legtöbbet tud
nekünk nyújtani pihenség, regeneráció,
növekedési hormon szempontjából, az a
remázis, illetve a mélyalvás szakasza.
azért, hogy rendbe tudjam tenni a
kérdéseket, meg az elméletet az emberek
fejében, ezért felbontom az alvási
szakaszokat. Tehát egy átlagos
felnőttnek körülbelül 7 és 9 óra közötti
alvásmennyiségre van szüksége. Ez a nagy
átlag.
Vannak, akik már 5-6 óra alvással is
nagyon jól működnek, van olyan is,
akinek 9-10 óra szükséges. Ezeket
gyakorlatilag nem lehet általánosítani,
ezt mindenki kell tapasztalja saját
magán.
Viszont
>> itt lenne egy gyors kérdésem. Ez ezt
honnan lehet tudni, hogy mennyi olvásra
van szükségem? Mert az egyik
tapasztalatom az az, hogy egyrészt
befolyásolja az étkezés, az
alkoholfogyasztás, tehát hogy oké, ez ez
ez mindenképpen ott van, de egy
gyakorlat kérdése is, tehát hogyha egy
fegyelmezett 10 napon van, akkor nekem
könnyű felkelni. Tehát akkor mondhatnám
azt, hogy kevés alvásra van szükségem,
vagy azt is mondhatjuk, hogy becsapom a
testem és valójában tök kevesebbet
alszok, mint amennyit amennyire
szükségem lenne.
>> Ühüm.
Meg kell ismerjük a saját alvási
kronotípusunkat. Ez az egyik
legfontosabb dolog. És ahhoz, hogy ezt
megismerjük, ez kell egy kell végeznünk
gyakorlatilag egy kis önkutatást. Egy
mini kutatásba bele kell menjünk.
>> Ez mi ez a kronotípus?
>> Az alvási kronotípusok. Hát ezzel a
90-es években, illetve a 2000-es évek
elején nagyon sok alváskutató szakember
foglalkozott, de igazából akkor vált
igazán ismertétté meg népszerűvé ez a
téma, amikor Michael Bus alváskutató
orvos, illetve klinikai pszichológus
ismertéte.
Azelőtt
több ilyen avás kutatással foglalkozó
szakember leírta azt, hogy vannak a
tipikus reggeli emberek, a pacsirták és
a tipikus esti emberek, a baglyok.
Michael Beus szerint viszont négy alvási
kronotípust különböztetünk meg. Ezek szó
szerint az oroszlánok, a medvék, a
farkasok, illetve a delfinek csoportja.
Ezeket, hogyha nem gondolok ki is fejtem
néhány szor.
>> Olyan mint valami csillagképek, úgyhogy
kicsit fejts ki nekem, hogy ne ne a
asztrológiához jussunk. Igen. Tehát az
oroszlán típus azok az oroszlánok, vagy
hogyha a régi megfogalmazás szerint
mondjuk, akkor ők a pacsirták, ők a
tipikus reggeli emberek, viszonylag
könnyen ébrednek reggel és viszonylag
korán, tehát ilyen 6: óra környékén
általában már kipattan a szemük, reggel
fel vannak ébred és elindul az élet.
Nagyon jól tudnak teljesíteni a
délelőtti időszakban. Itt vannak a
toppon. Ha valaki magára ismer ebből a
típusból, akkor neki itt jó a reggeli
edzés, a reggeli mozgás. Itt kora reggel
már tud dolgozni, jól tud szellemileg is
teljesíteni.
Viszont ennek az a az a az az egyéni
sajátossága, hogy délutánra már el is
fárad úgymond és viszonylag korán ágyba
kell kerüljön, tehát kimerül és elfogy
az energiaszintje.
Következő kategória medvék. Ez
gyakorlatilag a az átlagembernek a
legnagyobb, tehát legnagyobb populációt
érinti. azt mondják felmérések, hogy a
lakosság fele, tehát 50%-al ebbe a medve
kategóriába tartozik.
Reggel viszonylag közepesen indul, de
nem annyira korán, tehát ilyen tipikusan
ilyen 6-78 órakor tudnak felkelni.
Nincsenek a legnagyobb, tehát nem
nincsenek toppon reggel, de viszont
elindul a reggeljük. Tehát hogyha
megfelelő
reggeli rutint kialakítsák, akkor jól
tud indulni a reggeljük is. A legjobb
teljesítményük mentálisan az dél
délelőtt 10 és dél környékén, délután
1-2 óráig van. Tehát ez a ez az a
három-4y óra, amit érdemes olyankor
kimaxolni, vagy arra arra időzíteni a
legfontosabb tennivalókat, vagy amikor
nagyon kell koncentrálni. Délután
általában van egy egy ilyen
hát egy ilyen kisebb energiavesztés
általában kettő és né óra között szó
>> ez ilyen ebéd utáni igen, de nem biztos,
hogy csak az étkezéssel függ össze,
hanem ez egy ilyen az ők saját
krontípusuknak a saját jellemzője, hogy
kettő-4 óra között van egy kis
energiavesztés.
viszont 4 óra után, tehát én 5-6 óra
megint felpörögnek egy kis időre, és
viszonylag normális időpontban, tehát
ilyen este 10-11 órakor tudnak menni
aludni, és viszonylag jól is alszanak.
Ezek voltak a medvék. Vannak a farkasok,
vagy régi besorolás szerint a baglyok,
akiknek borzasztó nehez nehézükre esik a
felkelés. Reggel egyáltalán nem tudnak
teljesíteni.
Nem tud, tehát néhány órán keresztül
kovájugnak, alig akar elindulni a
napjuk. késő délutánra tehető a az a
pont, az az időpont, amikor ők
mentálisan fókusz fókuszban tudnak
lenni, és a legjobban tudnak
teljesíteni, és este nagyon fel tudnak
pörögni, és este nagyon jól tudnak
teljesíteni, nagyon tiszta lesz a
memóriájuk, nagyon tiszta lesz a
gondolkodásuk.
Ezek voltak a farkasok vagy a baglyok,
és késő éjjelbe is bele tudnak menni.
nagyon elhúzódik az alvási ciklusuk,
tehát akár éjfél, évjfél után érzik azt,
hogy el kell menjenek lefeküdni, de
viszont emiatt ugye belemennek abba,
hogy a következő reggel az megint nem 6:
órakor kezdődik nekük, hanem ők elhúzzák
8-9 akár 10 óráig, és nehezen fog
indulni a következő napjuk is. És akkor
vannak a delfinek, ez viszonylag kevés,
a populáció kevés százalék-át érinti,
talán ilyen 10% körül van. Ők azok az
emberek, akik akik nagyon rossz alvók. A
legkisebb szisszenésre is megébrednek,
felületes az alvásuk.
Leginkább az az a jellemzőjük, hogy
folyamatosan kattog az agyuk valamin.
Rengeteg információ van benne,
cikálnak a gondolatok a a fejükben, és
ez nem hagyja gyakorlatilag őket
megfelelően pihenni.
Az idegrendszerük gyakorlatilag emiatt
egy kicsit kimerült kimerültebb
állapotban van. Tipikus jellemzője az,
hogy rosszul alusznak. És
az energiaszintjük az sosincsen a
csúcson, tehát egész nap ugyanazon az
energiaszinten vannak, nincsenek ilyen
kiemelkedő részek, viszont ez sosem
nagyon alacsony, sosem nagyon magas.
Tehát nincsenek úgy, mint a medve
típusnál például, vagy a farkastípusnál,
hogy este teljesítenek a legjobban,
hanem ők nagyjából ugyanazon a szinten
élik a mindennapjaikat.
Nincsen kimeg kimagasló szakas, és
nincsen olyan, hogy hogy csökken a
teljesítményük. Ugyanazon az
átlagszinten vannak egész nap. rossz
alvók és könnyen ébrednek.
>> Te amúgy melyik vagy?
>> Érdekes, mert gyakorlatilag egy több
hónapos vagy több éves
kísérletezés után jöttem rá arra, hogy
valahol a farkas és a delf közé sorolom
magamat. Elképzelhető az is, hogy
ez így az elmúlt évek
két gyerekes családapa vagyok, és annak
is elképzelhető, vagy betudható, hogy
viszonylag könnyen ébredek. Tehát én a
leg, ha az egyik gyerek egyet mozdul,
vagy bármi, akkor én arra megébredek, és
nem mondom azt, hogy nehezen tudok
visszaaludni, de viszont viszont érzem
magamon a következő napomra ez
egyértelműen kihatása van, főleg akkor,
hogyha ez egy éjszaka többször
megtörténik. Tehát ebből a
megfigyelésből és abból, hogy én az esti
órákban nagyon-nagyon jól tudok
koncentrálni, fókuszálni, olvasni,
tanulni, kutatásokat böngészni, bármi,
>> én a farkas és a delfin közé tenném
magamat. Elképzelhető, hogy ezek a
kronotípusok nem mindenki egy tiszta
farkas, vagy nem mindenki egy tiszta
delfin kronotípusba sorolható, hanem
vannak ilyen átfedések. Úgyhogy én
valahol a farkas és a delfin kronotípus
közé tenném magamat.
Úgyhogy én nagyon komolyan kell
dolgozzak azon, hogy hogyan alszok,
hogyan pihenek, milyen technikákat
alkalmazok. És a nagyon jellemző az,
amit mondtam a delfin típusnál, hogy
folyamatosan az emberben cikáznak a
gondolatok, rengeteg információ van a
fejben, rengeteg gondolat van, rengeteg
teendőlista van, rengeteg olyan
információ van.
>> Ezzel mit lehet kezdeni, mert azt hiszem
nem vagy egyedül.
Az én technikám az, ami ami nekem nagyon
sokat tudott segíteni, és azt érzem,
hogy ettől megnyugszok, ki tudtam
üríteni a fejemet, az, hogy jegyzetelek.
Tehát jegyzetelek akár papír formájában
van notesem és
>> így az ágy mellett van egy notesed és
egy írószer, amúgy hogy le azt a noteszt
azt sokszor hordozom magammal. ö megvan
meg a telefonomban a jegyzet, az azt
azért nem mutatnám meg senkinek, hogy
hogy néz ki, mert több 100 jegyzet van,
és azok a jegyzetek is több több
oldalasak, és abban vannak
x-ek, amiket nem sikerült teljesíteni,
vannak zöld pipák, akiket sikerül
teljesíteni, és az a lényeg, hogy a napi
teendői listámat, a napi feladatokat, a
napi terveket, célokat vagy megoldandó
problémákat, ezeket mindig leegyzetelem.
Nagyon sokszor van az, hogy ez ez estére
marad, és akkor hogyha ez benne maradna
a fejemben, akkor ez folyamatosan ott
lenne, és folyamatosan járnának a
gondolatok, és nem tudnám elengedni
magamat mentálisan, nem tudnék
gyakorlatilag nem tudnám kiüríteni a
fejemet. Nekem ez segített nagyon sokat,
hogyha tudom, hogy leírtam, tudom, hogy
megvan, akkor sikerül egy picit
elazulni, sikerül egy picit elengedni
ezeket, és következő nap, mikor indítom
a napomat, akkor elő tudom venni azt a
jegyzetet a telefonon, vagy akár papír
formájában, és látom azt, hogy mi az,
amit az előző nap sikerült megoldani, mi
az, ami átkerült a következő napra,
esetleg kibővítem, hogy még mik a
további feladatok, és ez nagyon-nagyon
sokat tudott segíteni abban, ag
>> hogy nem pörög az agyam. Így van. És nem
nem kattogok rajta. Így a az egyikkel
tehát az ez egyik aspektusa talán ennek
még, amiről kéne beszéljünk, az a
képernyőidő. Sokat hallok arról, hogy ha
este 10 után most nem tudom milyen fénye
kérik az embert, az az pont úgy fent ezt
te tapasztaltad magadon
>> mindenképp. Sőt én használok, nem mindig
sajnos, de használok fényszülőszemüveget
estére, ami egy ami szűri a mesterséges
kék és zöld fényeket. Ezzel van a
legnagyobb probléma. Tehát rengeteg ez
klinikailag biz
>> de ez tényleg működik, mert én magamon
nem tapasztaltam feltétlenül, de lehet,
hogy olyan kicsi hatása van,
>> ami ami ami tényleg működik, és ez
mérhető, és ez ez bizonyított tény, az
az, hogy a mesterséges fények, leginkább
a kék és zöld fények, ezek egyértelműen
rontják a melatonin termelésünket.
Hogyha romlik a melatonin termelésünk,
akkor gyakorlatilag
alvás, minőség, romlást tapasztalhatunk.
Megfelelő melatonin termelés nélkül. Nem
lesz jó minőségű az alvásunk. És a
mesterséges kék és zöld fényekkel van a
legnagyobb probléma. Ezek a szemüvegek,
ami amilyen van akár nekem is, de most
már nagyon könnyen beszerezhető. Nekem
néhány éva megvan. Egy ilyen olyan
lencse van benne, mintogyha
narancssárgás, vöröses lenne. Tehát a
meleg színeket meleg meleg színekké
teszi. Gyakorlatilag nem annyira
élvezhető. Például egy egy filmet nem jó
vele nézni, de viszont hogyha az esti
órákban fenn legyen valaki, akkor és
mondjuk muszáj laptopon vagy
számítógépen dolgozni és valamiket még
meg kell oldani, akkor ezen keresztül
nézni a kijelzőt, ez sokkal
egészségesebb minden nélkül az
alvásunkra nézve, merthogy kevésbé
operációs rendszernek van ilyen
beállítása is, de ezek működnek.
>> Í van. Ezek működnek. Ezek ezek valós
dolgok. Ezek valós dolgok. És érdemes
szerintem kihasználni a mai attól e
lehetőségeket, technológiákat, hogy egy
kicsit sárgásabb lesz a kijelző. Én nem
mondom, hogy teljes mértékben lehet
csökkenteni, mert nem lehet teljes
mértékben kiszűrni a mesterséges kék és
zöld fényeket. Ö viszont minimalizálni
lehet a káros hatást, de nem csak a
kijelzővel van probléma, hanem a
környezetünkben lévő világítással is.
Tehát maga az irodai környezetben, ahol
egész nap ülünk, vagy a legtöbb ember
ül, az otthoni világítás is. Tehát
általában mi a jellemző a mai modell
lakásokban? Az, hogy hideg fények
vannak, fehér hideg fények. És hogyha
néhány évtizedet, 50 6080 100 évet
visszanézünk, akkor ott a melegfények
domináltak. gyertyafény, petróleum
lámpa, tehát a sárgás melegfények
voltak, a kandaróban égő tűzfénye. Tehát
a melegfények domináltak, és ezeknek a
melegfényeknek, ezeknek sokkal jobb
hatásuk van a megnyugvásra, illetve
arra, hogy nem csökkentik a saját
melatoni termelésünket. Igen, ebbe a
skand most így a skandinávikeás dizájn
jut eszembe, ahol gyakran ez a félhomály
sárgás hangulat van esténként, és ez ez
tényleg van egy van benne vonzó, valami
otthonias benne.
>> Rendben, menjünk akkor egy lépéssel
tovább, de még maradjunk az alvásnál.
Van-e valami olyan aspektusa az
alvásnak, amit esetleg kiemelnél, ami
gyanítom, itt nagyon sok minden van,
amiről még beszélgethetnénk. Például a
remázisról egy kicsit mesélnél nekünk,
hogy mi miért is fontos ez pontosan,
melyik része az a ami igazán pihent
minket.
>> Így van. Tehát a rendfázis az rapiday
movement szakasznak a rövidítése, amikor
gyakorlatilag ez a fázis azért fontos,
mert itt a gondolatainkat és az
érzelmeinket gyakorlatilag tudjuk
rendezni. Hogyha ez az embereknek
kimarad, akkor általában másnap sokkal
ingerlékenyebbek. ö sokkal dühösebbek,
sokkal érzékenyebbek lehetnek. Ezért
fontos a remázis, hogy megfelelő
szakaszokban menjen végbe.
>> Itt tényleg amúgy gyorsan mozog a szem,
mint ahogy mondj, tehát ebben a fázisba.
>> Igen, igen. Igen. Szemmozgás
megfigyelhető ebben a ebben a
szakaszban. A mélyalvás szakaszában
viszont, ami szerintem legalább
ugyanolyan fontos, mint a mint a
RAMfázis, ott viszont gyakorlatilag
fizikailag regenerálódunk. Ö ebben a
szakaszban termelődik a legnagyobb
mennyiségű növekedési hormon, ami nem
csak azért fontos, hogy egy gyerek
esetében a növekedést is biztosítsa és
azért felelős, hanem a sejtjeinknek a
megújulásáért, a a sejtjeinknek a
regenerációjáért egy nagyon-nagyon
fontos hormonról beszélünk.
Ö külföldön már használnak
növekedési hormonpótló készítményeket
is. Tehát külsőleg pótolják a növekedési
hormont. Ugyanis ennek a hormonnak az
öregedésre nagyon-nagyon jó pozitív
hatása van. Tehát lassítsa az öregedési
ütemét. Később öregszünk, ugyanis a
sejtjeink jobban regenerálódnak és
úgymond nem használódnak el. Egy ilyen
ilyen antiaging technika gyakorlatilag.
És ezt én nem azt akarom promoválni,
vagy nem azt akarom javasolni senkinek
sem, hogy ezt a hormont ő külsőleg
pótolja, vagy külsőleg juttassa be a
szervezetébe, hanem hogy aludjon mélyen,
mert a mélyavás fázisában mi kellő
mennyiségű,
>> tehát gyakorlatilag, ha nem alszunk jól,
akkor gyorsabban fogunk öregedni.
Egyértelműen kimutathatató ez azért,
mert csökken a növekedési
hormontermelésünk.
>> És a jó alvást az nem az alvás
hosszározza meg, hanem az alvásnak a
szakaszai, tehát az alvásnak a minősége.
Itt nagyon sok ember
a mai világban már okos készülékek
segítségével méri az alvási fázisokat.
Ezek nem pontos adatok. Tehát ez
nagyon-nagyon fontos kiemelni, hogy akár
egy óra, vagy akár egy gyűrű, ilyen okos
gyűrűk, vagy okos órák vagy pántok
segítségével mérhető alvási fázis, az
csak egy kiindulópont, tehát az
megközelítőleg saccolja.
>> Tehát nem pontos, de ennél pontosabb
van-e? Ennél pontosabb
>> alvási laborokban végezhető csak.
ugyanis oda a agyi hullámokat kellene
mérni és ahhoz meg komoly berendezés
komoly kés
>> de gondolom hogyha elmegyünk egy
laborba, akkor már változik a környezet,
változik minden körülöttünk, ami miatt
másképp fogunk aludni. Van olyan is,
amikor ezt kiadják otthonra, tehát hogy
ezt a készüléket odaadják, el lehet
vinni. Néhányat kell aludni vele otthon.
Van, ahol nem adják ott, és úgymond
hotelszerű labor, és akkor bent kell ott
aludni. De viszont
viszont azok pontos mérések, azok mérik
az agyhullámokat, és azokban tényleg az
mérhet, azzal tényleg konkrétan
számatokkal mérhető, hogy milyen hosszú
volt az tényleges alvás, nem csak
megközelítve, annak mennyi volt a
remázisa, hány százaléka-a volt a deep,
tehát a mélyalvás, mennyi volt a
nemrfázis, illetve voltak-e mikro
megszakadások az alvásban, mikro
éébredések, vagy akár hosszabb
ébredések? Rengeteg embernek problémája
az, hogy éjjel horkol, és rengeteg
embernek problémája az, hogy éjjel
alvási apnoé apnoéja van. Tehát
gyakorlatilag
néhány másodpercre, vagy hosszú
másodpercekre is kimarad a légzése, és
ez hatással van. Tehát akinek apnója
van, vagy szinte mondhatnám azt is,
akinek aki rendszeresen is hosszú időn
keresztül horkol, az nem pihen jól. Ott
az alvásminőség nagyon-nagyon romlik.
Amúgy az órával kapcsolatban nekem az a
tapasztalatom, hogy valószínűleg tényleg
nem fontos, de mégis mondjam úgy, hogy
elég jó. Tehát, hogy van, az azért egy
fontos visszajelzést, hogy például,
hogyha alkoholt iszok, akkor az órám
kimutatja, hogy az első pár órában
egészen py éjjel egyigőig valahogy
mintogyha nyugtalan abból aludtam volna.
Ez gyanítom, hogy a a gyorsulás mérő és
a szívritmus mérő, amelyik folyamatosan
mér, az abból kombinálja össze az
adatokat. De meglepően pontos. És hogyha
tegyük fel egy egy fegyelmezett estét
tudok tartani, amikor ezt az időszakos
böjtöt betartom, és és akkor akkor
nagyon-nagyon sima viszont az olvásom.
>> Ühüm.
>> Úgyhogy nem tudom, te használsz ilyen
fitness eszközöket, vagy ilyen órát,
vagy gyűrűt, vagy valamilyen? Igen.
Néhány éve, szerintem most már egy ilyen
három-négy évere tippelem, én egy matrac
alá építhető szenzort vásároltam, aminek
a segítségéel mérem az alvásomat. És az
elég érzékeny. Az úgy működik, hogy be
kell dugni, tehát 220 V kell neki, van
egy kis átalakítója,
tehát nem elemes. Az a lényeg, hogy nem
kell ezzel akkor foglalkozzak, vagy
cserégetni az elemet, vagy az
akkumulátorát tölteni. Úgyhogy ez
vezetékről működik. És a megvan a gyártó
garantálta azt, hogy nem tudom hány
centiméter matrac vastagságig működik ez
a mérés. És annyira érzékeny, hogy a
matrac vastagságán keresztül, tehát ez a
matrac alá van helyezve, volt egy ilyen,
ugye általában az ágyak alatt vagy egy
ilyen rácsos szerkezet van, vagy
valamilyen egyenes felületű rész, és oda
kellett berakjam.
viszont ez miután behelyezzük a a
konnektorba, felfúlyódott és annyira
érzékeny, hogy észreveszi azt, nem csak
az, hogy én lefekszek és magától indul,
tehát nem kell semmit indítani rajta
applikáció, semmi ilyesmi, hanem mindent
érzékel és a matrac vastagságán
keresztül méri a pulzusomat meg
mindenféle adatot, tehát érzékeli azokat
a kis dobbanásokat.
Na, itt nagyon sokszor az van jelen
esetben nálam, hogy például éjjel
megérkezik a valamelyik gyerekem mellém,
odabúik hozzám, és akkor teljesen
összezavar összezavarodik a rendszer,
vagy sokszor az olyan, hogy hogy ők már
el vannak menve, ugye ők általában
időben fektessük a gyerekeket, én még
fent vagyok, akkor ő befekszik az én
helyemre, vagy odamászik, vagy bármi,
keresztbe fekszik, akkor ez a szenzor
már elindul, valamit már érzékel, majd
érkezek Én mondjuk 11 órakor lefekszek
én is, és akkor azt mutatja, hogy én már
9 órától az ágyban vagyok, és éppen nem
tudtam elaludni. Tehát a a statisztikai
adataim azok nem szépek és nem
luknyezettek a gyerekekkel. Igen, igen,
de viszont viszont nekem nekem én azért
választottam ezt az eszközt mérésre,
mert engem borzasztóan zavar minden.
Tehát borzasztóan zavar, ha bármi rajtam
van, tehát úgy a karórám vagy bármi. Én
tipikusan az az ember vagyok, nem vicces
lesz elmondani, de én még a gyűrűmet is
lehúzom minden este, és minden este
lehúzom, és nem tudok jól ugrni, hogyha
még a gyűrűm is rajtam van. Minden
minden tehát az a delfin, amit mondtam,
hogy a legkisebb rosszul alszom és
minden zavaró, minden zavar éjjel és
minden zavaró tényező megságból, hogyha
ennyi mindent tudsz az alvásról,
mennyire tudtad ezt a delfint típusodat
megóvni, hogy hogy milyenek az alvási
minőségeid? hogyha mindent jól csinálok,
mindent optimálisan csinálok, az azt
jelenti, hogy tehát mentálisan is
készülök erre, ahogy mondtam, leírom a
jegyzeteimet, kürittem a fejemet
satöbbi.
A figyelek arra, amit amit már amiről
már beszéltünk, hogy a mesterséges kék
és fény fényeket kerüljem, vagy
használják szemüveget. Általában az a
javaslat, hogy elalvás előtt legalább
egy órával ezt a digitális detoxot
próbáljuk meg elindítani, úgy a fényekre
nézve, úgy a
TikTok, közösségi oldalok satöbbi, mert
az a rengeteg információ egy delfin
esetén, ami én is vagyok, amint
meglátunk egy képet, meglátunk egy
videót, ahol rengeteg
információmennyiség és rengeteg ingér
jön velünk szembe. Főleg ezekbe a
felgyósított videókba, amit mi kapunk,
az valami eszméletlen. hogyha ezeket be
tudom tartani, akkor jelentősen, tehát a
az eszközöm segítségével is mérhetően
jelentősen javul a mélyvás, illetve a
rendfázisom is.
>> De viszont, hogyha ezekre nem figyelek
és nem készülök az alvásomra, akkor én
ezt másnap nem csak érzem, hanem amikor
megnyitom az applikációt és megnézem az
alvás minőségemet, akkor azt látom, hogy
a mély alvás fázisom az szinte eltűnt,
tehát nagyon-nagyon lecsökken. És ez
nekem rossz, mert érzem is a másnapomon.
Ez kihatással van a másnapi
teljesítményemre, úgy a családban, úgy a
vállalkozásban, úgy a sportban egyaránt.
És
és akkor ez gyakorlatilag amikor már
ránézek az applikációra, már az
feldühít, hogy meglátom az adatokat.
[nevetés]
A
>> beszéljünk egy kicsit az alkoholról. Te
iszol-e alkoholt amúgy?
>> Ritkán. Ritkán fogyasztuk alkoholt,
tehát így a hétköznapi életben
egyáltalán nem. Tehát valamilyen
eseményhez köthető.
Ö és hogyha az érdekel, hogy milyen
hatásra van ez az alvásra, illetve pont
ide [nevetés]
>> van-e van-e akár pozitív effektje vagy
negatív effektje, akkor akkor ebbe
menjünk bele.
Ugye nagyon sokáig az a az élt az
emberek fejében, hogy napi egy pohár
vörösbor elfogyasztása az kifejezetten
egés kifejezetten egészséges. Ennek
antioxidáns tartalma van, rezveratról
tartalma van. A francia franciáknak és a
francia borok fogyasztóinak meg
kedvelőinek jó a szívrendszeri elhalzási
mutatójuk, és hogy ez védi a
szívrendszert.
>> Ezt gyanítom, hogy ilyen francia
borpincészetek finanszírozták ezt a
kapá.
>> Elképzelheti, hogy elképzelhető, hogy ez
is benne van. Ma már tudjuk azt, hogy a
legkisebb mennyiségű alkohol is kihatása
van a bélnyákahártyára. Tehát oldja,
roncsa, roncsolja a bérnyálkahártyát. És
azt is tudjuk, hogy a legtöbb betegség
az a bendszerből indul ki. Tehát
gyakorlatilag összefüggésbe hozható az,
hogy bármilyen kis mennyiségű alkohol,
az negatívan befolyásolja az az emberek
általános egészségét.
>> Ühüm.
Visszatérve az alvás és alkohol
kapcsolatához, amiben az alkohol tud
segíteni, és nagyon sok embert, akivel
beszéltem, és alkoholt fogyasz
rendszeresen elalvás előtt, az a maga az
elalvás, tehát hogy maga az, hogy hogy
nyugtat, tehát lenyugtat és és
elfáraszt, vagy álmos leszel tőle, és
maga az elalvásban, de viszont az alvás
minőséget az kifejezetten roncsolja.
Tehát töredezetté válik tőle az alvás.
És mi történik alvás során? az emberi
szervezet lenyugszik. Tehát hogyha
megfigyeljük azt, hogy ha valaki jól
alszik és mély alvásban van, akkor és
például egy okoseszköz segítségével
mérjük a púzusát, akkor látható az, hogy
az éjjeli púzus az csökken a nappali
pulzushoz képest.
>> Igen.
>> Az alkohol növeli a pulzust, tehát az
alkohol hatására a pulzuszám meg pont
növekedik. Tehát itt már alapból egy egy
nagyon ellentétes dolog van. töredezetté
válik az alvás, felszínessé válik az
alvás, és jóval kevésbé, tehát hatással
van a mélyalvás, illetve a refázisokra
is, tehát jóval kevésbé megyünk be a
mélyalvásba, mert felszínes alvást
fogunk aludni. Úgyhogy az alvás minősége
az jelentősen romlik az alkoholnak
köszönhetően. Na most, hogyha oda
gondolunk vissza, mint az előbb
említettem, hogy mi történik éjszaka
alvás közben, csökken a púzusunk és
csökken a légzések percenkénti száma is.
Tehát mélyeket lélegzünk, viszonylag
keveset lélegzünk, kevesebbet lélegzünk,
lenyugszunk, a testhőmérséletünk is
csökken. Na most ez lenne az optimális.
Ezért ezért kellene rengeteg olyan
technikát alkalmazzunk, ami nem kerül
pénzbe, nagyon kevés energiába és nagyon
kevés kicsi koncentrálásba kerül. Ilyen
például egy elalvás előtti
légzőgyakorlat. A tipikus kockalégzés,
vagy dobozlégzés, vagy 44 légzés.
>> Ez gyakorlatilag amúgy az egyik
legtöbbet foglalkoztatott
légzéstechnika, és nagyon egyszerű
dobozlégzés a legelterjedtebb neve.
abból áll, hogy négy másodpercig szívjuk
be a levegőt. Tehát ezt így magamba
magunkba számoljuk. Majd miután
beszívtuk négy másodpercig a levegőt,
akkor tartunk négy másodperc szünetet.
Utána négy másodpercig fújjuk kifele a
levegőt, akkor akkor jön négy másodperc
újabb szünet, és akkor kezdődjük előré,
utána négy másodpercig szívjuk be a
levegőt.
Ez nagyon-nagyon kimutathatóan nagyon
nagyon nagyon jó nyugtató hatássa van.
Tehát segíti az elalvást is, akik
nehezen alusznak, alszanak el, tehát
hogy azt tapasztalják önmagukon, hogy
próbálnak elmenni időben lefeküdni, de
csak nézik a plafont és várják, hogy
valami történjen. Próbálják meg ezt a
ezt a légző gyakorlatot beiktatni az
esti rutinjukba. Ez egy ágyban, egy
ágyban végezhető légző gyakorlat, és
nagyon jól lenyugtassa az idegrendszert,
nagyon jól ellazít,
>> meg gondolom unalmas is számolni,
úgyhogy már hát unalmas is, tehát ha
néhány kört az ember megcsinál, akkor
akkor abba bele fog aludni, és ne
várjuk, tehát ne várjuk azt, hogy már az
első alkalom után működjön, de ha valaki
kitartó és két héten keresztül csinálja,
akkor biztos vagyok benne, hogy az
emberek nagy százaléka pozitív effektet
fog érezni tőle, könnyebben el fog tudni
aludni. nyugodtabban fog aludni. És ami
kell, ami kell az alváshoz, a jó
minőségű alváshoz, az hogy csökkenjen az
éjjeli légzésszám, csökkenjen a
testőmérsékletünk, csökkenjen a
pulzuszámunk, ez a légző gyakorlat már
előre segíti.
>> Ez gondolom napközben is, hogyha egy
stresszes a napunk, akkor akkor bármikor
elő alkalmazható. Ez bár ez a
légzőgyakorlat bármikor alkalmazható.
>> Apropó stressz, most egy kicsit fogok
ugrálni a témákba, de itt logikailag ide
tartozik. olyan érdekes statisztikát
mutatott az egyik kliensem, együtt
dolgoztunk, és volt egy nagyon stresszes
időszak, amikor az egyik munkatársunkkal
komoly problémák voltak, és két héten,
két hónapon keresztül ez ez tényleg napi
szintű stresszet jelentett, és utólag
mutattam meg, hogy az órája kimutatta,
hogy azokba a hónapokba átlagban 10zel
volt több a pulzusa. De de ez egy
haviátt, tehát hogy hogy h nem az volt,
hogy volt egy stresszes nap, hanem két
hónapja volt stresszesebb, amikor amikor
átlagban 10zel volt nagyobb a pulzusa.
Hihetetlen volt. Tudod mi lenne még itt?
Érdekes adat, hogyha ebbe a két hónapban
látnánk a vércukorszint értékeit is,
ugyanis
egyenes kapcsolat van a kortizol vagy
egyéb stresszhormonok, illetve a
vércukors szintben is. Ugye sokszor
halljuk azt, hogy ha valaki felidegesít,
akkor azt mond azt azt mondják a
hétköznapi nyelvben kicsit székelyesen,
hogy felvitte a cukromat.
>> Üm,
>> és ez nem és ez ez nem hülyeség. Tehát
gyakorlatilag jelentősen a stressz
hatására, a kortizol hatására jelentősen
emelkednek a vércukor értékek.
Miért? Én erre mondok is egy nagyon jó
példát.
Hogyha a természeti népet vagy a
természetben ér minket egy hatalmas nagy
stressz, akkor ez elindul egy folyamat,
elindul egy reakció, amit mi majd fel
fogunk használni, vagy el fogunk
fogyasztani, és ez szükséges. Nagyon jó
példa itt Erdélyben az, hogy sétálsz,
gombázol az erdőben, és két 10 mre két
fával odébb meglátsz, szemben nézel egy
medve, mi történik. Az, hogy nagyon
megijedsz, egy hatalmas nagy stressz
téged.
>> És ennek a hatalmas nagy
stresszhormonoknak köszönhetően az
egekbe ugrik a vércukorszinted. Miért?
Azért, hogy te tudjál csúcstményt
leadni. Tehát olyan dolgokat vagy képes,
olyan testményt vagy képes abban a
pillanatokban leadni, amire amúgy nem
ezt a de ezt a hatalmasra ugrott
kortizolsz szintet és egyéb
stresszhormon szintet. És ezzel egyenlő
mértékben felugrott vércukors szintet te
el is fogod használni, mert vagy
sprintelni fogsz, vagy fára fogsz
mászni, vagy olyan fizikai teljesítményt
fogsz nyújtani, amivel el is használod.
>> H
>> a hétköznapi embert éri rengeteg sok
stressz, de ezek általában lehet ülve
elolvas egy olyan emailt, hogy érzi,
hogy elrobban a feje, de utána üdögél
tovább a székbe, és nem használja
elesztet. Tehát érted, hogy mi a
különbség? Az, hogy az egyik az egy
olyan stressz volt, ami ami kellett
azért, hogy mi lehet, hogy éppen azért
élünk túl, és elhasználjuk ezt a
felemelkedett vércukorszintet. De hogyha
te ülsz az irodában a laptopod előtt, és
érkezik egy olyan email, vagy egy olyan
SMS, vagy egy olyan információ a másik
oldalról, amitől neked érzed, hogy a
fejed elrobban, és rengeteg sok stressz
ér, ez ugyanúgy fel fog emelkedni a
vércukorszintet, csak éppenséggel te,
hogy ezt levezessed, max egy nagyot ütsz
az asztalra, de nem fogod azt, nem fogsz
te fára mászni, vagy nem fogsz egy
hatalmas nagy sprintet.
>> Ez egy kitérő lesz. vissza fogunk térni
az alváshoz szerintem, de ezt most
muszáj tovább vigyük, hogy rendben
dolgozunk az irodába, időnként ér
egy-egy ilyen faktor, és akkor ha elég
jól tudunk magunkra reflektálni, akkor
most tudjuk, hogy most ez egy stresszes
pillanat. Amúgy zárójelben az órám
ilyenkor szól, hogy tegyek egy take a
break, hogy hogy tartsak egy szünetet
vagy egy légzésgyakorlatot, mert mert
>> kocka dobozlégzés,
>> dobozlégzés szuper. De hogy akkor
ilyenkor ajánlod például az, hogy menjen
ki valaki, próbáljon meg sétálni, vagy
hogy valami tudom, egysőfekvőtámasz,
vagy valami, amivel hirtelen valamennyi
energiát le tud vezetni.
>> Abszolút, abszolút. A lényeg az, hogy
hogy itt emelkedett minden. A
stresszintek emelkedtek, vércugorszintek
emelkedtek. hogyha bármilyen fizikai
aktivitást itt tud végezni, csak elmegy
sétálni, vagy elmegy megbeszélni. Tehát
nagyon sokszor szokták is azt
alkalmazni, hogy irodai munkásoknál,
hogyha van egy megbeszélés, az akkor
mondjuk két ember között, egy
felsővezető és egy vezető között
valamilyen egyeztetés van, akkor azt nem
muszáj, hogy így leüljünk egymástól
szembe, hanem el lehet menni egy parba,
és sétaköz megbeszélni ezeket az
információkat, vagy ezeket az
információcserét, és ez sokkal
optimálisabb, sokkal egészségesebb
lenne. Miért? Ha ugyanabban az irodai
környezetben maradunk, akkor ugyanúgy
minket csak a környezeti mesterséges
fények vesznek körül. Ha már kimentünk
az épületből, az már egy váltás.
Találkozunk természetes fénnyel. Ha bent
maradunk az irodában, akkor ugyanazt az
elhasznált levegőt szívjuk. Ha kimentünk
a szabadba, akkor nem csak a természeti
fény, hanem egy frissebb, oxigénúsabb
levegő is.
>> Igen. És azonnal, tehát hogy
>> és azonnal. És akkor ne beszélj vel
arról, hogyha itt mi ülünk egymással
kezd, vagy az a két személy ül egymással
szemben, és beszélget, akkor továbbra is
ül.
és nem mozog. És az az tudjuk azt, hogy
már egy 40-50 perces folyamatos üléstől
jelentősen romlik a vérkeringés az egész
szervezetben. Ha megmozdulnak és
elmennek egymás mellett sétálni, attól
meg javul a vérkeringés. Ha jobb a
vérkeringés, akkor az több tápanyagot,
több glükózt és több oxigént szállít
mindenhova. Így az agyunkba is. Jobb
javulnak a kognitív funkciók, élesebb a
mentális fókusz, minden minden jó. Ha
most jönne hozzád egy ilyen irodavezető,
és azt kérné tőled, hogy van egy kicsi
pénzünk és egy kis hely is a az irodába,
valami eszközt vásárolnánk, amivel le
tudjuk le tudják vezetni ilyenkor a
stresszet tegyük fel, hogyha most éppen
nem egy megbeszélendő valami, hanem
egyszerűen tényleg a a munkával járó
valamilyen stressz, akkor miket
ajánlanál, hogy milyen eszközöket
vásároljanak, vagy hogyan lehet
levezetni egy irodai környezetbe az
ilyen stresszet?
Azért nehéz ez, mert
az irodában
lévő dolgozók között jelentős fizikális
különbségek lehetnek. Tegyünk csak
különbséget egy nő és egy férfi között.
Ugye ezért, hogy ez mindenkinek
megfeleljen, vagy mindenki tudja
használni, ezért a legjobb az, hogyha
valamilyen akár saját testsőlyos edzést
végez, vagy mozgást végez. Ehhez ehhez
nagyon jó eszköz lehet egy TRX. Ismered
a TRX-et?
V alakú kötelet, amit
ott meg mindenki a saját testsúlyja
segítségét használja, és ott lehet
javítani, tehát lehet növelni a
teljesítményt a testsúlyunknak a
bedölésével. Lehet húzómozdulatokat
végezni, lehet tolómozdulatokat végezni,
mindent meg lehet csinálni. És így az a
jó, hogy nem az van, hogy van egy 15 kgs
súlyzónk ott helyben, és az lehet, hogy
az egyik egyénnek kevés, és a másik
egyénnek meg meg túl sok. Itt mindenki a
saját testsúlyát használja, mindenki a
saját
erő és állóképességét tudja alkalmazni,
ugyanis ezt lehet fokozni, minél jobban
bedőlünk, minél jobban rádőlünk a saját
esőnkkal. Ez az egyik, amit a következő
az pedig gumiszalagok, mert ott is
különböző erősségű gumiszalagok vannak,
és minél jobban kinyújtod, minél jobban
összefogod, minél jobban összehajtod,
annál nehezebb lesz. És itt is lehet
játszani, lehet földről emeléseket.
Tehát itt a nagyon nagy probléma az,
hogy az a rengeteg ülés, tehát egy
irodai dolgozó 6 10 órán keresztül ül,
és alig mozdul meg, ugye
már ahogy mondtam az előbb is, 40-50
perc után nagyon nagyon nagyon romlik a
vérkeringés és ez az egész szervezetben
úgy általánosan. Tehát javasolt lenne
az, hogy akár fél óránként öt percre,
vagy óránk, vagy 50 percenként egy 10
perces szünetet kivegyünk, és azt
töltsük mozgással, mozduljunk meg. Ez
lehetne, ezek lehetnek
dinamikus mozgások, tehát dinamikus
nyújtógyakorlatok, például rugózások,
válkörzések, tipikus gimnasztikai
gyakorlatok,
>> vagy egy pingpongasztal,
vagy egyball asztal. Most beszéljünk egy
kicsit a bullról is, mert közel volt
hozzánk az esemény. Igazából bármi, ami
amitől amitől az ember jól érzi magát,
és egy kicsit felpesdül a vérkeringése,
picit megemelkedik a pulzuszáma és egy
kicsit magába szív nagyobb mennyiségű
oxigént. És ez lenne és és hogyha ezt
még tudjuk fokozni azt, hogy ez a
tevékenység még ne az iroda falain belül
legyen, hanem kint az a 10 perc, kint a
friss levegőn és kint a természeti
fényben, akkor ez lesz a csúcs
kategória. Gyakorlatilag, hogyha
óránként 10 percet erre rá tudunk
szánni,
>> ez ez nagyon nagyon tud működni
hosszúvon. És általában mérhető a
teljesítmény, tehát jobb lesz így a
teljesítmény, hogy hiába annak ellenére,
hogy mondjuk egy 8 óra alatt 8 percet
vesz itt a munka idejéből úgymond, de
mégis a napi ös napi öszteljesítményt
visszahozza, mert azokban az 50
percekben sokkal jobban tud teljesíteni,
és lehet, hogy az első három fázisban,
az első háromszor 50 percben nem annyira
észrevehető ez, de a délutáni órákban,
hogyha folyamatosan ezt fenntartotta,
akkor a teljesítmény annyival nő, hogy
ezt Ezt a vesztett, úgymond vesztett, de
nem veszt, ezt magunkba fektettük, nem
vesztettük el. Ezt a vesztett nyolcszor,
hatszor, nyolcszor vesztett 10 percet
mindenképpen tudjuk kompenzálni. Jobb
teljes
>> Igen. Amúgy itt megemlíteném még azt,
hogy én sokáig használtam és igazából
most így, ahogy beszélünk róla, fogok is
használni egy ilyen emlékeztetőt, ami
egy ilyen notifikációként felugrik, hogy
50 percenként 10 percet szüneteljünk.
Sőt, egy ideig azt is csináltuk, hogy
volt egy ilyen tablet a falon, ahol
publikan úgymond mérte az időt, és
egyszerre mindenkinek jelezte, hogy na
most van 10 perc, egy picit olyan gyári
hangulatnak tűnik, de valójában amikor
egyszerre szünetelünk, akkor van egy
lehetőség arra, hogy dobáljunk egy
labdát, vagy kimenjünk. Ha mindenki
külön-külön szünetel, akkor ez nem nem
szokott megtörténni.
>> Úgyhogy ez tényleg ezzel jól szokott
működni. Mi a helyzet az emelhető
asztalokkal?
Nagyon jó, szerintem nem fogja
helyettesíteni a mozgást, tehát
semmiképpen sem lehet kiváltani a
mozgást. Viszont megvannak az előnyei.
Legtöbb irodai dolgozó panaszkodik
azért, hogy fáj a háta, fáj a dereka.
Illetve nagyon sok ember
tapasztalja azt, hogy a egy idő után az
ülő ideggel valamilyen probléma lesz,
begyullad, fáj, lesugárzik az akár a
lábba. Úgyhogy ezt valamilyen szinten
lehet csökkenteni, de a mozgást az nem
helyettesíti.
Aktívabb állapotban van az idegrendszér,
tehát az egy nagyon-nagyon fontos dolog,
mert általában
amikor ülünk, akkor picit úgyzulunk,
eltunyulunk, és az idegrendszer sem
annyira aktív állapotban marad, hogyha
valaki ugyanezt emelhető asztalnál
ávaval végzi, akkor egyrészt tudja
csökkenteni a hátfájdalmakat leginkább
deréktájékon. Tehát ez egy ez egyértelmű
dolog.
illetve aktívabb az idegrendszer, és
ezáltal élénkebben meg jobban lehet
dolgozni. Tehát, hogy lehet, hogy jobb
minőségű, jobb teljesítményt tud
nyújtani állva az asztalnál, mint ülve
az asztalnál.
>> Igen. Így az elmúlt időszakban többször
így feljött, és elkezdtem gyakorolni ezt
a csüngést vagy függést, hogy hogy azt
mondják, hogy ha naponta egy percet is
valahonnan így csüngünk, akkor ennek
nagyon sok pozitív hatása van szerintem.
is van valami benne. Tehát, hogy hogy
egy érzem azt, hogy a vállaimat és a a
az egész gerincemet ilyen szempontból
meg nyújtja és és rendesen érzem, hogy
mintogyha ha tehermentesíteni egy
pillanatra így a testemet. Erről te egy
kicsit tudnál mesélni? Veled is szembe
jöttek ezek a dolgok, vagy
>> mindenképpen? Tehát az, hogyha
te lógsz valamilyen formában, akkor az
egyértelműen a gravitáció hatását
kihasználva nagyon-nagyon jó hatással
lesz.
>> It most amúgy a hallgató kedvért nem a
húzózkodásról beszélek, hanem csak
egyszerűen simán lógás csak simán
lógásról. Így van. És ez jó hatással van
a gerincoszlopodra, illetve jó hatással
van maga a az egész nap a gravitáció
által összenyomott csigolyáidra, illetve
maga a hátizmokra is. Mondok ennél
érdekesebb dolgot és érdekesebb
információt ezzel a lógással vagy
csüngéssel kapcsolatosan. Amikor te
megfogsz egy rudot és abba kapaszkodva
lógsz, akkor érdemes ezt lemérni, hogy
hány másodpercet vagy képes lógni. Tehát
vannak is ilyen, nem tudom, hogyha
találkoztál vele, különböző ilyen
versenyszámok, hogy mérik időre, és
hogyha nem tudom, neked sikerül mondjuk
két percet meghaladva lógni, tehát ott
ott azért úgy trükköznek, akik ezt
csinálják, hogy nagyon vastag a root,
tehát nem tudod rendesen átfogni,
illetve az a rú azér nem egy fix rot,
hanem mozog igen egy ilyen csapágyos
rendszeren van, és forog, az már nagyon
nehéz teljes meg
>> gondolom egy hegymászó kell legyél
ahhoz, hogy az két percig bírt, hogy
olyan markolati erőd legyen.
>> Igen, így van. viszont itt a marokerő
fontosságára szerettem volna kitírni,
tehát nagyon-nagyon érdekes kutatások
jelentek meg azzal, hogy mik azok a
mérhető adatok, amik előrejelzik a
várható élettartamunkat.
Sok minden van pulzustól elkezdve
satöbbi, satöbbi. Az egyik legérdekesebb
adat az a marokerő, maga a szorítás.
Tehát hogyha valakinek egy igazi jó
kézfogása van, akkor az várható élet
hossza az jelentősen jobb lesz, mint
annak, akinek gyenge a fogása és gyenge
a marokereje. Ezzel a lógással ezt is
fejleszted. Jó, de itt hirtelen felmerül
a kérdés bennem, a cinikus oldalam az
hozza fel, hogy valakinek az életmódja,
ha azt eredményezi, hogy erős szorítása
van, talán más, mint az, hogyha valaki
tudatosan edz arra, hogy erő teljesebb
legyen a marokszorítása, de az életmódja
nem változik. Tehát, hogy most el tudok
képzelni egy kétkezi munkást, aki akinek
mint a beton a keze, amikor megfogod, de
azért lett ilyen, mert ilyen az
életmódja. versus valaki, aki
folyamatosan próbál edzeni, és a
fejkarja vagy az alkarja erősebb emiatt,
de minden más el van hanyagolva. Mi a
véleményed erről?
>> Persze, tehát felhozhatunk példának egy
alkoholista kőművest, akinek
valószínűleg olyan fogása lesz, mint a
satu, és mellette meg lehet, hogy egész
egész nap olyan életmondot él, ami nem
éppen optimális.
Egyér tehát egyetértek ezzel a
megközelítéssel, de nagyon érdekes ez az
adat. Tehát nagyon-nagyon érdekes ez az
adat,
>> az biztos, hogy egy váratlan adat, meg
könnyeb mérhető.
>> És könnyen mérhető. Így van. Vannak
olyan készülékek, amik amik akár
elektronikusan így rászorítasz, és akkor
ezt méri, hogy mekkora a szorítóerőd, a
marokerőd. És nagyon érdekes számodat
az, hogy és ez friss, tehát ez ilyen,
tehát talán ilyen 23 24
év vége körüli adat, hogy ezt így
kimutatták, hogy nagy átlagba mérve
azoknál, akiknél jó a marokerőszorítás
és erős a fogásuk, ott a várható
élettart az hosszabb.
>> Hm. És az a jó, hogy ezt nem én találtam
ki. Tehát, hogy maximálisan egyetértek
azzal, amit te mondtál, hogy az egyéb
életmódi tényezők nagyon-nagyon
befolyásolják természetesen a a
halálozásunkat és a várható éveinknek a
számát.
Itt van egy érdekes dolog, az hogy
mennyi statisztikailag a várható
életéveinknek a száma, de van egy
nagyon-nagyon fá egy másik és kicsit
fájóbb számodat, hogy mennyi a várható,
egészségben eltöltött éveinknek a száma.
És a kettő nem ugyanaz.
>> Erre még nem gondoltam, de ezt lehet
statisztikailagil előrez.
>> Erre van adat. Erre vannak adatok. Igen.
És talán kiemelkedő adatokkal bír Málta.
Tehát, hogy ott szint
>> Ja, igen. Hogy hogy ott ott minimális az
az idő, amit
>> minis az idő, amit betegen töltünk, mert
hiába lehet jó a várható előre
meghatározott várható élettartalmunk,
lehet 80-85 év is, hogyha abból csak
50-55 év a mi egészségben eltöltött évek
száma, és a maradék 20 évet úgy érjük
le, hogy lehet, hogy ágyba fekve, vagy
lehet úgy, hogy gondozni kell minket.
Tehát, hogy
>> gyanítom itt az orvostudomány
fejlődésével a betegségben eltöltött
időt ki tudtuk húzni, és és pont az
történik, hogy régebb ilyenkor hamarabb
meghaltak az emberek.
>> Pontosan
>> és most kihúzódik ez az idő. Egy kicsit
akkor erről tudnál mesélni, hogy hogy
melyek azok, amik csökkentik ezt a
betegségben eltöltött időt?
>> Mindenképpen az életmód, tehát hogyha
így meg kellene határozni, az aktív
életmód, a táplálkozás és az egyéb külső
tényezős hatások. Tehát én ezt erre a
három dologra bontanám. Aktív életmódról
sokat gondolom, nem kell beszélni, tehát
hogy a mozgás az az életünk része
kellene legyen. Itt egy annyit kitérnék
azért, hogy civil civilizációsan,
visszamenőleg, evolúciós
az ember az nagy mennyiségű mozgásra
volt tervezve, és ehhez vagyunk
hozzáetőan
ez a nom életmód, ez a vadász gyűjtögető
életmód. Vannak olyan adatok, amik azt
mondják, hogy naponta 10-20 km
megtételére voltunk képesek minden nap
hosszú távon, éveken keresztül, nem üres
kézzel, hanem tárgyakat cipelve. Tehát
itt ez az érdekes benne pontosan, hogy
valaki megcsinálhat naponta nem tudom
hány ezer lépést, és azt is méri az okos
eszközel segítségével. De viszont azt
lehet, hogy éppen egy MP3-at hallgatva,
zenéket hallgatva optimális körülmények
között tette meg. Ugyanezt őseink
megtették
>> úgy, hogy tárgyakat cipeltek közbe. És
gyakorlatilag
hogyha csak egyetlen egy
mozgásmintát taníanék meg az embereknek,
vagy javasolnék, hogy mit építsenek be
az életükbe, az az, hogy fogjanak meg
két nehéz netcet. Igen.
>> És menjenek el egy gyalog bevásárolni,
és gyalog vigyék azt haza. Tehát két két
két szatyórral, ne autóval kényelmesen,
hanem ez egy hasznos dolog is, mert
vásárolni szinte mindenki jár, ugye, aki
nem magának termel meg mindent.
>> És ha elmegyünk bevásárolni, akkor
nagyon kényelmes az, hogy bemegyünk
autóval a bevásárló üzletig, és az üzlet
előtti legközelebbi parkolóba lerakjuk
az autót, hogy minél kevesebbet kelljen
odatolni még a kosarat is, és akkor a
kosárból átpakoljuk, a csomagtartóban,
meg hazamegyünk.
Ugyanezt meg lehetne oldani szerintem
kisebb bevásárlásokkal, hetente több
alkalomra, akár egy estis réta
részeként. Az, hogy üresen két szatyóral
besétálunk, ahova szeretnénk menni
vásárolni, majd azt megrakjuk annyira
itt itt ennek van egy van egy ilyen
kicsit így ilyen megszorító jelege is,
hogy valószínűleg kevesebbet fog költeni
az ember, mert hogy ezt haza kell, utána
vigye és gyalog, és akkor két szatyóral
utána haza. És ez tipikusan az egyik
olyan mozgás, ami egyrészt séta, tehát
egy szükségünk van rá, az emberek nagy
többsége kevés lépésszámot teljesít. És
a másik az, amit mondtam, hogy sétálva
cipelünk különböző nehéz tárgyakat. Ez
evolúciósan egy nagyon-nagyon fontos
dolog. Kicsit elkanyarodtam, de
visszatérek ide például a máltaiakhoz,
hogy ott miért olyan jó valószínűleg.
Tehát az egyik az, hogy az életmód
kérdésnek a mozgás a része. És itt azért
emelem ki azt, hogy mozgás és nem sport,
mert a sport az egy
a sportot azért végezi a legtöbb modern
ember, hogy pótolja a mozgásigényét. De
hogyha valaki egész nap mozgással tölti
a mindennapjait,
mezőgazdaság, állattenyészt és bármi
olyan jellegű, amivel amivel egész nap
mozog, nem biztos, hogy ő neki még abban
abban a napban még szüksége van sportra.
Nagyon függ attól, hogy mit csinál.
Nagyon függ az ő fizikai állapotától,
mert nagyon sok olyan olyan tevékenység
van, ami egyoldalú. Tehát, hogy kicsit
elcsavarodik tőle az ember. Az egyik
oldala erősebb, mint a másik oldala. És
ez igen és ez hosszú távon ez
hosszútávon negatív kihatással lesz az
izomrendszerre, negatá negatív kihatása
lesz a csípőjére, a gerincoszlopára,
mindenre igazából. Tehát, hogy ott is
azokban a a munkásoknál is megvan a
létjukosultsága, hogy beiktassunk
valamilyen erre specifikus
gyakorlatokat, hogy ezt próbáljuk
megkorrigálni, vagy a hosszútávú negatív
hatásokat minimalizálni, de hogy a
lényeg az, hogy mozgásra van nekünk
szükségünk. Ez lehet, nézzük, nézzünk
meg csak egy igazán aktív gyereket, hogy
már egész kiskorától kezdve
egész nap mozodnak a legtöbbük, ugye
tehát hogy kúsznak, másznak, sétálnak,
bukfenceznek, fejen állnak, ugrálnak,
mozognak. Neki neki ez a ne az emberi
szervezet. És valahogy az az érdekes,
hogy ahogy növünk fel, úgy ezt ezt
elveszítsük, vagy elmarad kimarad.
Apropó gyerek, én kíváncsi vagyok, hogy
olvastál-e ezzel kapcsolatban valamilyen
tanulmányt, hogy a családos szülők vajon
a a az az életminőségük jobb-e, mint a
singli embereknek. Tehát, hogy én
tapasztalom magamon, hogy három gyerek
hányszor bozdít ki a komfortzónából,
hányszor kell cipeljek, hányszor kell
akár őket, akár az ételt, és a az
biztos, hogy sokkal kényelmesebb lenne
az életem. De vajon ilyen szempontból a
kényelem nem-e pont azt okozza, hogy
valószínűleg hosszabb időt fogok
eltölteni a betegségbe, hogyha például
nem vállaltam volna a gyereket?
>> Ezzel kapcsolatosan nem olvastam semmit.
Viszont nagyon szorosan ide köthető az,
hogy van olyan tanulmány, ami azt
mutatta ki, hogy azok az embereknek a
szívérendszeri halálozásuk
a rátája sokkal jobb, akik kutyát
tartanak.
>> Hm. És az nem azért, mertogy
a kutya megvéd minket, vagy maga a
kutyának a közelé, hanem a napi séta.
Így van. A napi séta és a napi átlagos
mozgás, ez kutyákkal egyértelműen van
ezzel ezzel ezzel a témával foglalkozó
kutatás.
Úgyhogy így gyerekes családokkal
visszatérve nem olvastam ezzel, de
elképzelhetőek tartom, hogy hogy nem egy
őrült gondolat. Pontosan, merthogy azért
egy gyerekes család esetén ott jóval
több a fizikai aktivitás, többet kell
menni, többet kell mozogni.
>> Na, biztos, hogy a megvan ennek a
negatív effektje is, tehát hogy amikor
visszatérünk az alvás részéhez, akkor
éjjel többször kell fel az ember,
többször szakad meg az alvásra, rosszabb
minőségű az alvásra. És ahogy te is
mondtad, hogyha ott az éjfél körüli
periódusban megszakad az alvás, amikor a
legmélyebben kellene aludnunk, az milyen
kihatással van már? Lehet, hogy valaki
olyan típus, hogy nehezebben alszik
vissza. Vannak itt azért negatív dolgok
is, de mozgás mennyiségére visszatérve
egyértelmű szerintem az, hogy egy
kisgyerekes családanya vagy családapa
jelentősen többet mozog napi szinten,
mint az, akinek nincsen gyerek. Igen,
itt a mozgásnál az a gondolat jött fel
bennem, hogy én az elmúlt két évben
értettem meg valamit, és kíváncsi vagyok
a véleményedre. Én Én
a mozgásomat futással próbáltam
kompenzálni. Hajnalonta felkeltem,
elmentem futni egy órát, és és az
nyilván az már önmagában vagy 7000 lépés
pluszba, és éreztem is a hatását a a
napomon, és van volt egy olyan is, hogy
akkor kalóriát égetek egy-eg egy ilyen
gondolatom. viszont arra jöttem rá, hogy
valójában sétálva több kalóriát fogok
égetni, hogyha ha több ha kevesebbet,
tehát hogy nem annyira intenzív séta, de
több hosszabb, huzamosabb ideig.
Egyrészt lépésszámba sokkal többet tudok
lépni egy nap. Másik pedig az, hogy
lehetséges, hogy jobb, tehát h a kardió
szempontjából jobb a futás, de fogyás
szempontjából lehet, hogy jobb a séta.
Neked mi a véleményed erre?
>> Ez mindenképpen így van. Tehát
a pulzuszám az egy meghatározó tényező
az, hogy az edzéstartományon belül
milyen szakaszokban kerülünk. Mi a
futásnál, amikor magasabb a pulzus, ez
lehet akár egy tempósabb séta is, mert
azzal is el lehet írni. Egy nagyon
tempós sétával, főleg egy hegymenetbe
el lehet írni azt a pulzustartományt,
ami már nem a zsírregető fázisba
tartozik.
>> Melyik a pulzustartomány? A átlagban azt
szokták mondani, hogy a 120 maximum 130
felett, tehát onnan már átkerülünk egy
kardiovaszkuláris terhelésbe, ami nagyon
jó állóképességre, nagyon jó a
pulzusnak, nagyon jó a keringési
rendszernek, szívrendszer, tüdőkapacitás
mind fejlődik, de viszont az optimális
zsírégető tartomány az valahol 120-130
környékén van. Ez azért mondom ezt a
limitet, mert ez sok sok tényező
befolyásolja. Befolyásolja az adott
egyénnek az állóképessége, hogy ő egy
full kezdő, vagy már mondjuk két éves
sport rendszeresen. Meghatározza ez
meghatározzó tényező a pulzus számnál az
életkor. Tehát ezek mind olyan dolgok,
amik meghatározzák azt, hogy melyik
számunkra az az optimális
pulzustartomány, amiben kellene
végezzünk edzéseket, és akkor
meghatározza a cél. Az a célunk, hogy
javítsuk az állóképességünket, javítsuk
a szívrendszeri hatásokat, tüdő
kapacitását fejlesszük, vagy pedig az a
cél, hogy égessünk több kalóriát, és ez
zsírból történjen. Igazából maga kalória
mennyiségben nem biztos, hogy ugyanazon
az időintervallum alatt többet fogunk
égetni, de többet fogunk égetni zsírból.
>> Ühüm. Tehát a kalória mennyiség az
összelégetett összelfogyasztott kalória
mennyiség az lehet, hogy egy intenzívebb
résznél, egy sprinteknél, akár egy
interval tréningnél, egy heat
tréningnél, egy tabata tréningnél, ott
több lehet az ott mondjuk 40 perc alatt
több kalóriát égetünk el, 40 perc séta
alatt, de az összkalória mennyiség, amit
elégettünk zsírból, az a 40 perces séta
alatt több lesz, mint a 40 perces
intenzív alatt. eszméletlen. És az az
érdekes, tehát hogy a mesterséges
intelligencia ilyen szempontból számomra
egy olyan pozitív oldalát hozta az
életemnek, hogy sokszor az van, hogy
amikor valami intellektuális munkát
végzek, ez egy komplex gondolkodási
folyamat, és azt most az elmúlt két
évben azt csináltam, hogy kimentem a
parkba, és ilyen hangmódba, tehát ilyen
voice módba sétálgatva oldok meg valami
komplex feladatot, mert gondolkozok és
beszélek, és miközben sétálok, amúgy is
jobban tudok gondolkozni. De azon veszem
észre magam, hogy 3000 lépést léptem
azalatt, ameddig megoldottam valami
olyan dolgot, amit amúgy azelőtt a gép
előtt oldottam meg. Úgyhogy ez ez
számomra hatalmas hozadéka a mesterséges
intelligenciának. Nem tudom, hogy te
ezzel találkoztál vagy
>> Igen. És amit amit te mondasz, az hogy
kimentél, sétáltál, mozogtál, jobb a
keringésed, jobb az oxigénellátásod,
természetes fényért, oxigénsabb
környezedetért, ez mind javítsa. Én azt
figyeltem meg magamon, és tipikusan az
az ember vagyok, hogyha kapok egy
telefonhívást, és azt éppen a irodában,
üzletben ér, és az egy fontosabb hívás,
akkor én kell sétáljak, és én én az a én
az a sétálva telefonáló ember vagyok. Én
indulok elát fel Így van, így van.
Felveszem a telefont, és ahogy már
veszem fel a telefont, én a székből
állok fel, és indulok elsétálni. És ha
éppen bent vagyok, és csak bent tudok
menni, akkor bent sétálok, de a házban
is sétálok. Tehát megyek, ha otthon
vagyok, akkor a konyhából megyek át a
hálószobáb, át a nappaliba, és vissza,
és járom a köröket, és megyek fel alá,
mert egyszerűen így tudok jobban
fókuszálni, és sokkal, sokkal jobb
jobban tudok telefonálni, sokkal jobban,
jobban esik az egész dolog, és azt
érzem, hogy jobb a fókusz, jobban ott
vagyok fejben, ha csak ott üdögélek és
akár kihangosítva telefonálok, ott nem
vagyok ott fejben annyira.
>> Szuper. Szerintem egy mielőtt tovább
megyünk egy teljesen más témakörre, én
én egy kicsit összefoglalnám, hogy mit
ajánlanak. olyan cégvezetőknek, akik azt
szeretnék, hogy hogy a munkatársaik
jobban tudjanak fókuszálni,
egészségesebb életet életmódot tudjanak
folytatni. Tehát egyrészt ott volt az 50
perc 10 perces szünet.
>> Így van.
>> Legyenek emelhető asztalok, ha
megteheti, akkor ez egy plusz. Legyenek
eszközök például, ami nem foglal sok
helyet, ilyen valahol, ahol lehet lógni,
TRX hasonló dolgok, meg
>> meg egyáltalán a cég kultúrájába férjen
az bele, hogy felállnak az emberek és
kimennek. Tehát ne legyen ez a
hajtsárüzemmód, amikor maximalizálni
akarjuk a gép előtt eltöltött időt,
hanem legyen benne a kultúrában, hogy ne
szégyelje magát valaki, aki aki
>> egy nyolc órás munkaidőben, hogyha
nyolcszor 10 percet veszített az adott
munkál dolgozó, munkás
szerintem öszteljesítményben a
napfolyamán jobban fog tudni
teljesíteni, merthogy a friss levegőnek,
a friss környezetnek, a mozgásnak, a
jobb vérkeringésnek köszönhetően a
teljesítménnyel javulni fog a későbbi
órákban. meg pláne
>> igen. És akkor még ehhez hozzátenném
azt, hogy legyen benne az is a
kultúrában, hogyha valaki AI-al meg
tudja oldani a feladatnak egy részét,
mehessen ki, legyen meg az a bizalom,
hogy kihessen és úgy gondolkozzon, és és
amikor visszajön, tegyük fel egy 10 perc
séta után, már a már már van egy
modellje, amit már utána tud a gép előtt
használni.
>> Pontosan.
>> Nagyon nagyon hasznos. Szuper. Menjünk
akkor a másik szakterületedre. Ez a az
ét étel és a az étrend
területe.
Itt is végtelen a terület, hogy miről
lehetne beszélgetni,
de inkább rádbízom, hogy hogyan osztod
be, hogy miről szeretnél beszélgetni. Mi
az, ami maximalizálja az
energiaszintünket étrend szempontjából?
Először is, amikor étrendről beszélünk,
akkor szerintem mindig felvetődik három
fontos kérdés az emberek fejében. A
három kérdés az pedig úgy hangzik, hogy
mit eszünk, mikor eszünk és mennyit
eszünk. És ez ez mindig feltevődik
szerintem. És
arra a kérdésre, hogy
hogy mennyit eszünk, én nagyon
egyszerűen szoktam válaszolni, mertogy
nagyon eltérőek vagyunk, nagyon más a
fizikai aktivitásunk, nagyon más az
alapanyagcserél típusunk, ugye, hogy
mennyit égetünk-e nyugalmi állapotban.
is gondolom vannak olyan típusok, mint a
medve, delfénoroslán csak másképp
hívják.
>> Így van. Ezek az ektomorf, mezomorf és
endomorf testípus falépítések. Viszont
nagyon tehát Haris Benedikt módszerrel
ki lehet számolni azt, hogy egy
átlagembernek,
itt majd vannak ilyen fizikai aktivitási
szorzók, egy átlag embernek mi az az
elégetett kalóriamennyisége? Ezt hívjuk
metabol bazál, metabolizm bazál
alapanyagcsereinek,
amit elégetünk mi optimális körülmények
között, itt mindjárt kitérek, mert én
mondtam ezt, hogy optimális körülmények
között minden egyes nap az életünk
fenntartásáért. Az, hogy van
anyagcserénk, az, hogy lélegzünk, az,
hogy dobog a szívünk, működnek a
szerveink, gondolkodunk, jár az agyunk,
ezekkel mind ugye kalóriákat égetünk el.
Ezt ki lehet számítani, és a különböző
tényezők befolyásolják azt, hogy férfi
vagy nem. Tehát nem nem az egy fontos
befolyásoló tényező. Más is a képlet.
Nagyon érdekes. Tehát a férfiaknak és a
nőknek más kiszámítási képletje van.
Tehát férfi nő a nem az meghatározó
tényező, a magasság, a kilogram és az
életkor.
>> És ha ezeket beadjuk, ezeket az adatokat
ebbe a képletbe, akkor nagyon egyszerűen
meg lehet kapni azt, hogy mi ez az
alapanyagcsere kalória mennyiség, amit
mi felhasználunk napi szinten,
visszatérve oda, hogy optimális
körülmények között. Ez azt jelenti,
hogyha téged bezárnánk egy szobába,
ahol te nem csinálnál semmit, csak
lefeküdnél egy ágyra, és ott feküdnél
mondjuk 20-21 fokon, hogy jó,
kényelmesen érezzed magad, ne fázzál, ne
legyen meleged, és 24 órán keresztül
csak ott feküdnél, és semmit nem
csinálnál, akkor is elégetnéd ezt a
kalória mennyiséget.
>> Hm. Tehát ez az optimális. Ez az
optimális, de hogyha én ezt a szobát
elkezdem fűtteni, felfüttöm 35°okra,
akkor te többet fogsz égetni, és hogyha
lehűttöm és te fázni kezdesz, akkor
megint többet fogsz égetni és ugyanígy
meghatározó tényező egyéb dolgok is. Ide
jönnek azok, amit az előbb mondtam, hogy
fizikai aktivitási szórzók. Ezt kell
felszorozni. Erre vannak különböző
számadatok. Ez, hogyha valaki érdekli a
téma konkrétan, és ki akarja számítani
saját magán, akkor keressen így rá, hogy
Harris Benedict kalkulátor. Vannak
formulák, tehát nem kell saját maguknak
kiszámoljuk, kalkulátorok segítség
megadjuk ezeket. Nő vagy férfi, hány
kilogram, milyen magas és hány éves. És
akkor ebből ki lehet számítani. És
akkor, hogyha valaki ugyanazt akar, hogy
a mennyiséget fogyassza, amit kijött a
kalkulátorból, akkor van fenntartás,
tehát a fenntartódózis, hogy mennyivel
tudjuk megtartani a jelenlegi
testsúlyunkat. És ha ebből elveszünk, és
kialakul a kalória deficit, és ez minden
nap megtörténik, akkor elindul a
testsúly lefele. Ha valaki éppen növelni
szeretné a testsúlyát, akkor ehhez a
kalóriamennyiséghez hozzarakunk, és
akkor elindul egy pozitív kalória
mérleg, a testúly elindul felfele.
>> Jó, hát akkor szerintem át is
ugorhatunk. Ez
>> eg matematika gyakorlat.
>> Igen, igen. Át is ugorhatunk a
minőségre, hogy mit eszünk, mert az első
gondolatom az, hogyha a csokiból visszük
be, vajon ugyanaz-e, mintogyha hafiléből
Igen. Igen. Tehát ez a következő lépés.
Tehát most megválaszoltam azt, hogy a
mennyiség kérés az nagyon egyéni. Én
röviden úgy szoktam meghatározni vagy
megfogalmazni picit vic viccesen, hogy
>> ha valaki mondjuk háromszor étkezik,
mert
ez mondjuk egy ideális lenne egy
átlagember számára, mondjuk a napi
háromszori étkezés,
nagyon sok ember mondjuk többször
étkezik, ötször, hatszor, nyolcszor több
étkezésre bontja, és nagyon sokszor
ember csak egyszer étkezik a nap
folyamán egész nap. reggeltől esik
gyakorlatilag reggel elkezdi megy az
irodába, és akkor ott már jönnek a
dolgok. Ott van előtte a a mogyoróstál,
meg mellette a másik oldalon ott vannak
az aszalgyümölcsök. Ez egy Jobbik
verzió, de ott a csokoládi, a ropi, a
snackek, mindenféle. És akkor reggeli,
reggelizett, reggeli és ebéd között
folyamatosan jön be a kalória valamilyen
formában. Ezek általában valamilyen
gyorsan felszídó, rossz minőségű dolgok.
Akkor közben még lecsúszik két-három
cukros kávé is melléje, és akkor eljött
már az ebéd. De hát gyakorlatilag
reggeltől ebédig folyamatosan nevet
szelegetett folyamatosan. Tehát ez nem
nagy mennyiség, de de folyamatosan jött
be. Úgyhogy én meghatároznám a következő
lépésnek azt, hogy először lakjunk jól
háromszor. Tehát a jól lakottság érzése
ez egy fantas fantasztikus dolog és
nagyon-nagyon fontos, hogy ne csak
együnk egy picit, hogy azért, hogy
tudjuk elmondani, hogy ettünk, hanem
lakjunk is jól. Tehát a jól lakottság
érzésnek, mint érzésnek az elérése, ez
egy fontos dolog. Érdekességképpen
mondom el azt, hogy végeztek olyan
kutatást, ahol azzal foglalkoztak, hogy
ugyanazt az ételmennyiséget ugyanabból
az alapanyagból két csoportembernek, két
két különböző csoportnak adták. Ez jelen
esetben 2000 kalória környéke volt
ugyanabból az alapanyagból, ugyanazzal
az elkészítési móddal. Az egyik
csoportnak öt felé osztották az
étkezését. Tehát az gyakorlatilag volt
három normális étkezés és két kisebb
étkezés, de átlagosan úgy jött ki az a
2000 kalória 5 felé osztva, hogy
nagyjából 400 400 kalória, ez így
ötször. A másik csoport embereknek ott
viszont háromra osztották, tehát szinte
600 és 700 kalória között három étkezés.
Figyelték, hogy hogyan mi lesz a
reakció. Ugyanaz a napi beviteli
mennyiség. A nagy legfontosabb különbség
az volt, hogy a abban a csoportban, ahol
ötször ötször ötször étkezés volt, attól
az ételmennyiségtől ötször ettek, közel
voltak az étkezési étkezéseknek a
ismétlődése egymáshoz, de sosem laktak
jól. Mindig csak ettek és be kellett
fejezni, mert elfogyott az étel.
Utána három óra múlva mondjuk megint
tettek, de megint nem laktak jól, hanem
megint csak abba kellett hagyni az
étkezést, mert ennyi volt az a porció. A
másik csoportban háromszor étkezett és
háromszor mondjuk el is érte a jó
lakottság érzését. Sokkal
kényensúlyozottabbak voltak, sokkal
kevésbé voltak ingerültek, enerváltak.
Jobb volt a hangulat, mint a másik
csoportban, mert ez itt is hormonálisan
a gyomorban
és nem csak a gyomorban, hanem például a
barna zsírszövetben is termelődnek.
olyan hormonok, amik a jól lakottságért
és az éhségérzésért felelősek, és ezek a
hangulatunkra és az általános kedvünkre
is hatással vannak. És ezért fontos az,
hogy ne csak együnk úgy, mint egy kis
maroknyi ételt, hogy tudjuk elmondani,
hogy ettünk. Nem az a nem addig kell
lenni, mint egy karácsonyi vasoránál,
hogy utána beüt a kajakóma és elágyulunk
tőle, hanem de fontos az, hogy lakjunk
jól, tehát érezzük meg azt, hogy
delegott telítettség
>> érzése. Ühüm. és optimális esetben egy
étkezés az a jó lakottság érzését elérve
legyen elég annyira, hogy a következő
étkezési időpontig, ami amúgy jó esetben
legalább négy-5 órára kellene legyen,
kibírjuk úgy, hogy közben nem kell az
iroda asztaláról ropival meg
gyümölcsökkel meg satöbbel pótolni és
folyamatosan utána enni, hanem ott az
emésztőrendszer tudjon azzal
foglalkozni, hogy úgymond megpihen,
emésztődik az élelmiszér, felszívódnak a
hatanyag Jók, és nem az van, hogy
folyamatosan még utána
>> Igen. Meg ezek a nassolások általában
ilyen olcsó, finom szénhidrátokkal
történnek, hogy valami olyan, ami
felviszi a vércokorszintet, úgyhogy mert
azok az olcsóak, tehát nem pisztáciát
fogunk rágni, hanem hanem valószínűleg
valamit kipszet, ketmi.
>> Itt a telítettségérzésnél volt két
trükk, amit így hallottam. Kíváncsi
vagyok a véleményedre. Az egyik az, hogy
azt mondták, hogy sokkal telítettebbnek
fogjuk érezni magunkat, ha egy pohárvet
megisszunk étkezés előtt. Ez az egyik. A
másik pedig az, hogy a fehérjék azok,
amik tel azt a telítettségi érzést
adják. Tehát hogyha például
csirke mellett fogunk enni, sokkal
telítettebbnek érezzük magunkat,
mintogyha nem tudom zöldségeket ennél,
nem mintogyha kettő kettő között kéne
választani, de hogy tudjuk azt, hogyha
van a fehérje a tányérunkon, akkor a
telítettség érzés az sokkal teljesebb
lesz. Ez mi a véleményed ezekről? A
véleményem az, hogy nagy részben igaz,
de meg szeretném cáfolni ezt a
telítettség meg jól lakottság érzésben
kapcsolatos. Nagy általánosságban
elmondható az, hogy a fehérje jól
telitt, tehát a húsok általánosan, a
halak ezek jól telítenek.
Viszonylag hosszú az emésztési idő, nem
piszkálja a vércukorszintet, vagy
kevésbé piszkálja a vércukorszintet,
mint a szénhidrátok, és főleg a gyorsan
felszíódó szénhidrátok.
És egy nagyon-nagyon fontos dolog az,
hogy kevésbé vagyunk képesek
felhasználni ezt energiaforrásként. A
fehéréknek nem az a szerepe, hogy
energiát biztosítsunk számunkra, hanem
ez a fő szerepe. Arra ott vannak a
szénrátok és a zsírok. A fehérnek az a
szerepe, szerkezeti felépítésbeli
szerepe van a szer a szerzetünkben.
Gyakorlatilag minden sejtünk valamilyen
fehérjéből épül fel. A bőrünk, a hajunk,
az izomzatunk, mindenünk a különböző
fehérje típusokból épül fel. és a
fehéréknek még a hormonjaink is. Tehát,
hogy a fehéréknek ez a szerepe, hogy
különböző egyéb fehéréket készítsünk
belőle. Úgymond felhasználjuk ezt erre a
feladatra. Kevésbé az a feladatuk, hogy
számunkra energiát. Tipikusan van is ez
a ez a nyúléhezéses
vadnyúas téma, amit sokszor fel szoktak
hozni, hogy gyakorlatilag
úgymond éhen lehet halni, ha mondjuk
valaki csak vagynyúl húst eszik, mert
gyakorlatilag több kalóriát emészt fel
annak az emésztése, mint amennyit ad. És
hogyha valaki ezt heteken, hónapokon
keresztül valaki próbálta,
>> ezzel vannak vannak
azt hiszem, hogy volt is egy olyan
olyan valamilyen balesetes környezet,
ahol valamilyen ilyen vadhúshoz jutottak
hozzá, és gyakorlatilag ebből lett a
probléma. A teljes háttértorit nem
tudom, de viszont ez egy ez egy
kimutatott tény, hogy gyakorlatilag
a vadnyúl hús vagy egyéb vadhúsok is úgy
általánokban elmondható, hogy a
legtöbbjük az nagyon zsírszegény, tehát
sok kalória nincsen benne. Az emésztésük
rengeteg kalóriát igényel. És miben
gazdag? Nagyon fehérjében. De a
fehérjének nem az a főszerepe, hogy
energiát adjon. Tehát gyakorlatilag maga
a megemésztése az több kalóriát van el a
szervezettől, mint amennyihez
hozzájutunk. És ez tud lenni egy ilyen
fehérjés, te fehérje típusú éhezés.
Visszatérve a főgondolathoz, tehát a
fehérje nagyon jól tel itt, hosszú
emésztés és viszonylag kevés kalóriát
nyerünk belőle, de viszont erre van egy
lista, hogy melyek azok az élelmiszerek,
amelyek a legjobban terítenek, és ezeket
az élelmiszereket ugye általánosságban
azért érdemes beiktatni az az étrendbe,
mert hogyha ezeket rendszeresen
fogyasszuk, akkor ezek hosszú távon
terítettségérzést okoznak, és akkor nem
kell asoljunk azért ések között vagy
kevesebbet tudunk belőle enni. Nézzük
>> és meglepő lesz meglepő lesz az, amit
fogok mondani, mert a köztudatban ennek
pont az ellentéte van elterjedve. És
csak az elsőt fogom megemlíteni és a top
kategóriát, mert utána aztán a fehérje
típusok jönnek, de a legelső helyen a
főtt burgonya van.
És ugye mindenki meglepődik ezen, hogy
hát az szokott az első dolog lenni, hogy
akkor a keményítőket, a szénhidrátokat
az étrendből söpődjük kifele. Viszont
főtt burgonyával nagyon jól lehet
fogyni. Az egyik leghosszabban és a
legjobb terítettség érzést okozza az
emberi szervezetben. És ahhoz képest
kalória szempontjából meg nagyon kevés.
100 g burgonya körülbelül 20 g körüli
szénhidrát mennyiséget tartalmaz.
>> Ühüm. Tehát, hogy
>> a főt a nem nyers nyers formájában m
adat, amikor látsz egy statisztikai
adatot, 100 g rizső, 100 g burgonyárú,
bármi, ezek mindig nyers adatok.
>> Így van.
>> Összehasonlítva mondjuk a rizsel, ami
7080 g 100 gonkénti szénhidrát tartalom.
Tehát a burgonya 100 gonként csak 20 g
körül van, tehát négyszeres mennyiségű
szénhidrát van mondjuk a rizsben.
A főtt burgonya nagyon jól tel itt,
kevés szénhidráttartalommal,
diétázók legjobb barátja és mindig ugye
a köztudatban ez van elterjedve, hogy ha
fogyni szeretnél, akkor ezeket söpör ki
az étedből. Tehát nem a szalmakrumpliról
beszélgetünk, mert az már egy teljesen
más dolog. Igen. Itt ami ami ami
megzavar az, hogy egyrészt én azt
hittem, hogy 50 g körül van a a
burgonyának. Ezzel olyan adatot néztel,
amikor már elkészített
formában.
>> A másik pedig én azt hallottam, hogy
amikor megfőzzük a burgonyát és hagyjuk
lehűlni, olyankor pont, hogy csökken a a
szénhidrát tartalma amiatt, mert
felbomlanak a a a ezek a láncok. Tehát
rezisztens keményítő alakul ki a
hagyomány úgymond hagyományos
keményítőből, ami ami hát ellenálló,
ellenáll a rezisztencia, tehát hogy a
neve is ahogy mondja, ellenáll az
emésztésnek és különböző bakteriális
úton tudjuk ezeket megemészteni. És ez
azért jó, mert gyakorlatilag mint egy
prebiotikum úgy működik az emberi
szervezetben, tehát gyakorlatilag
tápanyagként táplálékul szolgál a a
bélflórán a mikrobiomunk számára, és
elősegíti azoknak a baktérium tőzsöknek
a a fenntartását, a szaporodását, ami
igencsak fontos tudjuk a mai világban,
hogy a gyakorlatilag
még akár a mentális jólétünkre is és a
gondolkodásunkra is kihadhat a belső
mikrobiomunk.
Igen, ez egy másik univerzum, amire
kitérhettünk, de szerintem nem lesz idő,
mert annyi más érdekes témám van. Én az
elmúlt évben elég sokat foglalkoztam a
vércokorszintel. Az én energiaszintemre
rájöttem, hogy hatalmas
hatással van maga az, hogy egyáltalán
nem tudtam, hogy ingadozik a vércukor
szinten. Egy csomó mindent nem tudtam
magamról. És a napomban főleg ezek a
nassolások, amikor égyomorra megettem
valami édeset, akár legyen az ilyen
szállított gyümölcs, ez hatalmasra lőtte
ki a vércukorszintemet, és utána aztán
leesett a vércukorszintem, utána pedig
kompenzáltam. Tehát gyakorlatilag egy
ilyen hullámzással járt, ami végig a
fókuszomat rontotta, a
kedélyállapotomat.
akik hajlamosak a depresszióra, azt
láttam, vagyis azt hallottam, hogy ezek
ezek még inkább fokozottabban,
negatívabban látja ilyenkor a világot,
ingerlékenyebb lesz, és nyilván, hogyha
elkezd ostobaságokat csinálni, akkor ez
kihat még tovább is.
>> És ez hosszú távon, ez hosszútávon ez
egyenes
út lehet, egy prediabétesz, egy
inzulinrezisztencia,
vagy akár egy kettes típusú diabétesz.
Én egyre több ilyent hallok, hogy hogy
inzulin rezisztenssé válnak a a
középkorú emberek. Tehát a már az én
korosztályomban egyre több helyről
hallom, ami bizonyos szempontból
szörnyű, mert rengeteg olyan láthatatlan
következménye van, ami egy ilyen
lefelevezőtő spirálba hozza az
életünket.
Én valamiért, ezért is fogtam neki pár
évvel ezelőtt, csak akkor még nem tudtam
a ketónak, és ki egy pár hónapig
kipróbáltam a carnivort is. Az az
igazság, hogy én azért nem folytatom
tovább, mert mert nem tudom túl jól
integrálni az életemmel. Tehát hogy nem
túl szociális, amikor elmegyek egy
vendégségbe, akkor nem tudok csak
ketogénni, és túl sok fegyelmet igényel
azért. És én szeretem a szénhidrátokat,
szóval az az igazság, hogy nem. viszont
azt tapasztaltam, hogy abszolút működik
az energiaszintem szuper volt a a a a
sport
>> stabil a vércukor és és te mi a
véleményed ezekről a a diétaípusokról?
Ketó meg carnivor meg próbáltad-e ezeket
egyrészt?
>> Persze. Hát a ketót azt a azt próbáltam
az hosszabb izé a testépítésnek a egyik
szakasza, nem? Ö igen. Tehát vannak
testépítők, akik ketogén diétával
készülnek, akár egy alapozási fázisban,
akár egy felkészülési fázisban. Nekem
felkészülési fázisnak egy része volt
ketogén étren, tehát a saját
tapasztalatom itt van.
Összességében azt mondanám, hogy inkább
terápia jellegű étrend amúgy a ketogén.
Tehát amiért megalkották, vagy amiért
létrejött ez igazából, hogyha
belemegyünk a múltjába, meg azért, hogy
miért volt ez létrehozva. az epilepsziás
rohamokat jelentősen csökkenti.
>> Igen.
>> Tehát terápiás céra nagyon jó, de
emellett emellett nagyon sok egyéb
terápiás felhasználása is szerintem
fantasztikus. Tehát több olyan tanulmány
van, ami azzal foglalkozott, hogy
daganatos megbetegedések esetén melyikek
a azok a azok a jó jól bevált módszerek
vagy étkezési szokások, amik sokat
tudnak segíteni. Az egyik ilyen a
ketogéntrend például, ugyanis hát ott
nincs szénhidrát, vagy nagyon-nagyon
minimalizálva van ugye a szénhidrát
bevitel, cukor nulla, tehát hogy ezek
mind egy egy daganatos betegség esetén
ezek fontos lépések és fontos mérföldek,
amiket meg kell tenni.
De ugyanígy,
ugyanígy a a paleo vonal is egy
nagyon-nagyon jó vonal tud lenni, csak
ott nagyon sokszor
ez a modernkori paleo, ez egy
élelmiszeri marketing lett
gyakorlatilag, és ezzel ahogy paleon név
alatt el akarnak neked már adni adni
termékeket. És itt is az van, hogy meg
akarják könnyíteni a modern ember életét
azzal, hogy te nem kell elkészítsd a
kajádat, hanem csak kibontod és
kicsomagolod és azt teszed meg. Erre már
egy hatalmas nagy élelmisz élelmiszeri
iparág felépült, és nagyon jó
marketingelve van és el van adva. De
hogyha a paleót lényegében megértsük,
hogy miről is szól
az őseink táplálkozása, vagy azazok az
élelmiszerek, azokat az alapanyagokat
fogyasszuk el, ami valaha egy élő valami
volt, egy növény volt, vagy egy állat
volt, és tényleg ezekre ezekre építsük
fel az étrendünket. Ez szerintem egy
nagyon nagyon nagyon jó irányvonal. és
az, hogy mindenféle szintetikus
élelmiszert, mindenféle becsomagolt
élelmiszert, mindenféle adalékanyagot,
feldolgozott, ultrafeldolgozott
élelmiszert próbálunk kiatni az
étrendünkből, és ezzel együtt próbálunk
minimalizálni, vagy teljesen
allerginmentesen étkezni. Ez szerintem
hosszútávú nagy, nagyon-nagyon
kifizetődő dolog lesz. Nem biztos, hogy
mindenkinek úgymond ez egy kötelező út,
hogy ebbe az irányba kell terelje az
életét. Van, aki úgymond kényszerből
valamilyen betegségek felbukkanása miatt
kerül bele, akár egy ketóba, akár egy
paleóba. ketóhoz visszatérve egy annyit,
hogy vannak olyan természeti népek, akik
sokszor ketó étrendbe kerülnek
természetesen. Tehát így a az ők
környezeti helyekün helykön olyan
élelmiszerek, olyan alapanyagok érhetőek
el, amivel nagyon-nagyon kevés
szénhidrát, vagy semmi szénhidrát nem
jut az étrendjükbe, és gyakorlatilag
ketózisban vannak, et hát egész évben.
Viszont vannak azok a természeti népek
is, akik az úgynevezett ciklikus ketogén
diétát követik. Tehát ciklizálva van és
termést az évszaktól függ
>> évszaktól függően igen megjelennek a
gyümölcsök, zöldségek bizonyos
periódusokban és akkor abból többet
esznek és az a zöldségek, gyümölcsök meg
gumósoknak a szénhidrát tartalma már
annyira megemeli, hogy a ketózisból
kiesnek, de utána amikor ez a periódus
lejárés már nincsen termés, akkor
visszaállnak azoknak az élelmiszereknek
a fogyasztására, inkább a zsír, inkább a
hús alapú étkezés, és akkor újra
ketózisban vannak, és akkor Ez ez így
ciklizálódik, tehát ilyen évszaktól
függően. Viszont van az a azok a népek
is, nagyon jó példának szoktam felhozni,
az eszkimókat, akik gyakorlatilagetó
az igen az egy és lehet, hogy karnivor
is ugye, merthogy merthogy gyakorlatilag
halakat
>> nagyon sok fókavért fogyasztanak és ez
gyakorlatilag halsír, halakból fehérje
források és ezeket fogyasszák és
érdekességképpen
nagyon-nagyon jó a szívrendszeri
halálozásuknak a mutató ója, tehát
nagyon-nagyon jó számokkal rendelkeznek
ők.
>> Gyakorlatilag ők nem ciklizálják a
ketót, hanem egész évben karnivor vagy
ketó étrenden működnek.
>> Amúgy nekem is eszmélet egyrészt a
súlyom drasztikusan csökkent, tehát hogy
négy hónap alatt ilyen lineárisan
összesen vagy tizen valamennyi kilót
fogytam, viszont nem volt fenntartható.
Az az igazság, hogy nem volt
fenntartható. És kaptam az idén egy
valamit, ami amiről külön egy epizódot
forgattunk. A ez a vércukorszintes
epizód, amikor amikor feldobtam Jess
Chuspinak ezt a glükózforrodalom
könyvét. Nem tudom, olvastad azt a
könyvet, vagy
>> ismerős? Ott két-három alapelvet mondok
el, és nagyon kíváncsi vagyok a
véleményedre.
>> Azt mondta, hogy már önmagában az, hogy
milyen sorrendben esszük meg az
ételeket, ezzel már le lehet törni a
vércukorszínek a a kicsúcsosodását. Én
vagy négy ilyen glüózmitort is
használtam. Amúgy a gyűrűdet is
leveszed, akkor gyanítom, hogy ilyen
glükóz monitort nem nagyon szeretnél
hordani,
>> de ilyen négy ilyen glüózmonitort is
használtam. Nagyon sokat figyeltem a
testem és tényleg működik. Tehát például
az első ilyen
tanácsa az volt, hogy ha van tegyük fel
egy tipikus
tányéron, amikor székely konyháról
beszélünk, van hús, van valami
savanyúság és van egy krumpli például,
akkor azt mondja, hogy a a savanyúsággal
kezdjük, utána pedig a hústyük meg, és a
végén pedig a a krumplit. Már önmagában
telítettségérzés meglesz. Viszont maga a
diagramja egy ellaposodott
kicsúc kicsúcsosodás lesz. Sőt, a végén
egy deszertet is elfogyaszthatunk. Mert
ha a deszertel kezdenénk, akkor akkor
viszont katasztrófa lenne a helyzet.
>> Pontosan.
>> És és még ezt még hozzátenném, hogyha
így gyomorra ennénk egy chipset, amit én
amúgy megcsináltam, és amúgy a abba az
epizódba be is másoltam a diagrammot,
egyszerűen eszméletlen. Tehát annyira
kiugrott egy 75 g-os chipstől, én meg
voltam rémülve, hogy tényleg létezik,
hogy egyetlen egy chipstől ennyire
kiugrik. Szóval már önmagában ez a
sorrend változtat. Akkor így bologatták
közben. De mi a véleményed erről?
mindenképpen jó rostokkal kezdeni, meg
meg olyan élelmiszerekkel folytatni,
amik jól telítenek, és nincsenek
hatással, vagy csak minimális hatással
vannak a vércukorra. Ezek a fehérje
források, tehát ahogy te is mondtad,
eleinte a zöldségrész vagy
savanyúságrész, ami amiknek nagyon nagy
a rostartalmuk és nagyon kevés a
szénhidráttartalmuk. Majd folytatni egy
olyannal, ami zsír meg fehérje egy hal
vagy egy hús formájában. szinten a
vércukorszintre minimális hatása van,
vagy szinte egyáltalán nincsen hatással,
és akkor a végére hagyni a szénhidrát
vagy keményítő forrásokat. Ezt ezt én is
ezt így vallom. Visszatérek egy olyan
gondolathoz, amit az előbb említettél,
hogy úgy lehet a telítettséget fokozni,
hogy étkezés előtt megiszunk egy nagy
pohárvet.
>> Igen. Erre nem reagáltál még?
>> Erre nem reagáltam, de nem felejtettem
el, mert
kérdés az, hogy ez milyen hatással, vagy
esetleg negatív hatással lesz az
emésztésünkre. Igen.
>> Sok olyan elmélet van, amit én is vallok
személyesen, hogy étkezés előtt legalább
fél órával be kellene fejezni a
vízfogyasztását, és étkezés közben
egyáltalán nem kellene inni, meg étkezés
után rögtön sem javasolítja a
gyomorsavat,
>> mert ja egyrészt, mert híg higítja a
gyomorsavat. Tehát ugye a gyomorban ott
egy jelentősen savas kőzeg van már
akinek, mert vannak sajnos olyanok,
akiknek nagyon elmegy, tehát elindul az
a az a pH érték, elkezd emelkedni és
elmegy a semleges irányába, ott már nem
lesz megfelelő a leginkább a fehéréknek
az emésztésé. Tehát a tipikus húsoknak,
vörös húsoknak, halaknak, bizonyos
tejterméknek az emésztése már nem lesz
annyira jó, mint megfelelő pH
környezetben, tehát megfelelő
savaskörnyezetben.
A víznek a pH-ja az természetes víznek
az valahol a hét környékén van,
semleges. Ha savas, akkor kicsit
savasabb lehet, hogyha valamilyen lúgos
vizet veszünk, mert ez is egy jó
marketing duma volt néhány évvel
ezelőtt, akkor lehet akár ilyen nyolc
feletti pH vizeket is kapni. Kérdés az,
hogy ez rögtön étkezés alatt vagy
étkezés előtt elfogyasztva ez milyen
hatással lesz, mennyire tud hígítani ott
a gyomorsak pH-ján, és ez egy fehérjében
gazdag étkezésnek az emésztési
hatásfokát milyen szinten fogja rontani?
Biztos vagyok benne, hogy egyéni kérdés,
mert nem vagyunk egyformák, és van
akinek jó sok mennyiségű sav
állrendelkezése, jó savas környezetben,
az kevésbé fogja észrevenni, de akinek
alapból már rossz a gyomorsava, nem
megfelelő mennyiségű gyomósaval
rendelkezik, és a pH-ja már úgymond
emelkedettebb, és ő még kaja közben vagy
kaja előtt közvetlenül azért, hogy a
terítettségérzés minél jobb legyen.
Legur itt egy nagy pohár lógós vizet.
szinte garantálom, hogy az emésztés
hatásfogá rontani fog. Hát azzal szoktam
példázódni, hogy mindig azt szokták
mondani, és van is ez a így a népben
elterjedt mondás, hogy az vagy, amit
megeszel, az vagy, ami fel is szívódik.
Tehát ez ez sokkal tehát hiába eszed meg
te, hogyha azt nem hasznosítod
megfelelően, nem emészted megfelelően,
elmondhatod, hogy te nem tudom mit
ettél, kaviárt ettél és osztrigát,
hogyha azt te nem tudtad megfelelően
megemészteni, az nem került be. igazából
akkor a sejtjei nem tudják ezeket
megfelelően felvenni és hasznosítani.
Úgyhogy nagyon fontos az, hogy ha meg is
esszük, akkor ebből hozzuk ki a
maximumot. És az én általános tanácsom
az, hogy étkezés előtt fél órával legyen
a vízfogyasztás. Étkezés közben ne
legyen egyáltalán folyadékbevitél.
Nagyon sokan úgy esznek, hogy még a
levessről is vizet isznak. Ez szerintem
nem a jó kategória. És étkezés után
próbáljunk meg ott is szintén egy 40
percet, akár 60 percet is várni a a víz
fogyasztásával. Ez ez szerintem a ez
lenne az optimális. Még egy gondolat egy
annyit a vízről, hogy ha valamilyen
szénhidrátban gazdag étkezést
fogyasztunk, akár ebben lehet egy
deszert is, vagy teljesen ne egy ebéd
ebéd részénél, és mi azt ott előtte vagy
közben bőven öblögessük vízzel, vagy
rögtön étkezés után, akkor a víz az egy
nagyon-nagyon jó oldószér. És ami jól
oldódik benne, az a cukor például. És
gyakorlatilag az étkezésben lévő
cukrokat feloldja a vízben, és ezáltal
sokkal magasabb vércukorszintem fogunk
tapasztalani, minthogyha nem innánk
közbe folyadékot. Tehát ez egy cukrosabb
vagy egy egyszerű szénhidrátokban gazdag
étkezésnél figyelhető meg.
>> Ühüm. Igen, ez a
terület az tehát akkor akkor kicsit
beszélgessünk magáról az italokról is.
Amúgy nem fogok kitérni most Jessek az
összes tanácsára, de például az egyik
tanácsa az volt, hogy igyunk ecetes
vizet, mert az segít abba a
vércukorszint letörésében. És csak
azért, hogy a hallgatók, akik esetleg
így elvesztették volna a fonalat, hogy
miért is beszélünk erről, a
vércukorszint ingadozás direkt
kihatással van az energiaszintünkre.
Tehát, hogy a az érdekünk az az, hogy
minél inkább ellaposítsuk ezt a görbét
mindenféle technikával, mert mindenféle
hatás ér azért, hogyha meg kell enni,
tehát egy olyan mindenki rendel így egy
deszertet és és akkor nem akarunk ilyen
szempontból szociálisan kilógni a a
többiek közül, akkor akkor ha megesszük,
akkor vannak bizonyos technikák, hogy
hogyan lehet azt a deszertet a lehető
legoptimálisabban
kezelni, úgymond, hogy a
vércukorszintünk. Most most még mivel
nincsen sok időnk, ezért nem térek ki
erre. Viszont egy kicsit beszéljünk
magukról az italokról, mert rengeteg
cukros ital van a a környezetünkben,
üdítőktől kezdve akár az
energiaitalokig, amelyek így
kirobbantják a a vércukorszintünket. Egy
kicsit tudnál mesélni arról, hogy
például most a az energiaszinten
mennyire segít egy energiaital.
Hát a tipikus energiaitaloknak, ha
megfigyeljük az összetételét, akkor
általában azt látjuk, hogy jó sok
koffein, tehát ilyen 100 mlben ilyen
általában ilyen 30 mg körüli koffein
mennyiséget tesznek bele. Most az
energiaital méretétől függően látjuk
azt, hogy vannak már akár ilyen fél
literes, nem akarok márkákat mondani, de
hogy az, hogyha megnézzük és
kiszámoljuk, akkor a akkor az ilyen 150
160 mg koffein tartalmazza.
Egy egy átlagos pressó kávé az ilyen
7080 100 mg környékén van. Tehát akár
egy energiaital az két erős kávénak a
koffein tartalamával is megegyező lehet.
Ö léteznek cukrozott meg édesítőszerrel
készült változatok is. Hát a cukrózott
lesz ott az igazából ami több energiát
fog tudni adni, mert Igen. Tehát jó sok
cukor benne. Most ez eltér szintén
gyártótól, de 100 mlenként 15 g, ugye
átlagosan 10-15 g környékére tehető a
cukortartalom. És amiket még tesznek
mellé bizonyos aminósavak, ilyen például
a taurin,
illetve különböző mér
>> mindjárt kitérek rá.
Sokan úgymond tartanak tőle, de mindjárt
meg fogok nyugtatni mindenkit a
taurinnal kapcsolatosan. Tesznek még mé
esetleg valamilyen növényi kivonatokat,
goronát, ginzenget, bármi ilyesmit, ami
egy kicsit így tényleg a mentális
fókuszba, meg akár a vérkeringés
javításában tud segíteni. Úgyhogy ez a
kombináció, és esetleg megszokták
turbózni. Ez nagyon-nagyon gyakori
különböző B-vitaminokkal. Ezt nem tudom,
hogy megnézed egy energiavitalnak a
címkét, akkor különböző B-vitaminokat
tesznek bele. Legtöbb B-vitamin az jó
hatással van az anyagcseréfolyamatokra,
fehérjék, széndidátok, zsírok
anyagcseréjére, illetve élinkítő hatása
van. Tehát ezeket kombinálják. Na most
kérdésedre válaszodva a taurin, tehát
mindenki fél úgymond meg van ijedve a
taurintól, hogy akkor általában, hogyha
meglátja azt a szót, hogy taurin, akkor
az jut eszébe, hogy energiaital, mert
ott találkozott vele a energiaitalitarok
címkején,
>> és
és attól tartanak, hogy ettől most a
Taúr szóból kiindulva te egy bika leszel
és erős leszel és és felspanolod
magadat, semmi köze,
>> semmi köze ez nem így működik, és és
gyakorlatilag a bikához semmi köze
nincsen.
A taurin az egy nagyon-nagyon fontos
aminósav, rengeteg jótékony hatása van,
és az egyik legfontosabb az, hogy a szív
és érrendszert jelentősen védi meg
támogatja.
Tehát elképzelhető,
hogy megfont megfontolandó az, hogy
azért van beletéve energiaitalokba, hogy
az egyéb stimulánsok által gyakorolt
pulzus meg vérnyomás emelkedést
taurinnal próbálják megkompenzálni. A
taurin az egy annyira egyszerű aminósav,
hogy nagyon sok élelmiszerünkben is
előfordul, viszont mi keveset eszünk
belőle azokból. Tipikusan a mediterráni
étrend, kagylók, rákok satöbbik, ezek
nagyon-nagyon tengergyümölcsei, ezek
nagyon-nagyon gazdagok
taurinaminósabban. Hát nem gondolom azt,
hogy az itteni székely ebből bőségesen
>> lehet, hogy azért van a máltán a a a a
az a hatások. mediteráni étrend az
egyértelműen kimutatod, hogy
élethosszabbító tulajdonságai vannak,
sok tényezős, de az egyik ilyen az a
tengergyümölcsei, rákok, halak,
jóminőségű kollagén, szelény cink, jót
bevitel, ezek mind mind fontos dolgok.
Viszont itt most visszatérve a taurinra
az egyik ilyen aminósav, ami ezekben
szintén ezekben az élelmiszerben nagy
mennyiségben előfordul, mi nem eszünk
elő mennyiségben. Úgyhogy a taurintól
nem kell félni. Egyéb olyan dolgok
vannak benne, amit ő sokkal jobban kell
tartani egy energiaital esetében.
Viszont viszont nem az a nem a taurin
lesz az. Mit csinál az energiaital?
Azt, amit egy egyéb cukros dolog is
képes kiváltani. Fellövi a
vélcukorszintet. Mellette jön még egy
koffein sokk is. Ez nem csak a vércukot
lövi, hanem a koffein hatása van a
stresszhormonokra. A kortizolt is viszi
együtt. Ezáltal púzusemelkedés,
vérnyomásemelkedés tapasztalható. Élénk
itt természetesen rövid ideig, amíg el
nem indul visszafele a
vércukorszínek a zuhanása.
>> Fogyasszal energiaitőlokat?
>> Egyáltalán nem fogyasztok. Amit néha
szoktam fogyasztani, azok azok ilyen
tipikus edzés előtti készítmények, ami
ami nagyon hasonlít egy energiaitalhoz.
De más az összetétel, tehát sportolókra
van szabva, egyéb dolgok vannak. Meg
utána jön a jegyzés is.
>> Utána jön egy jegyzés is, tehát azért
van elfogyasztva, de az sem
rendszeresen. Tehát vannak azok a napok,
amikor úgymond kell nekem azért, mert
annyira tele van a fejem, és lehet, hogy
lehet, hogy éppen a mentális fókuszomba
segít az, hogy tényleg oda tudjak
fókuszálni, és azt tudjam elvégezni azon
az edzésnapon, amit szeretnék.
elindít, elindít egy folyamatod benned,
jobb lesz a kedved, jobb lesz a
fókuszod, és akkor ettől jobban tudsz
teljesíteni. Viszont én utána és le is
dolgozom, tehát nem csak azért iszom meg
ezt a energiaitalnak nevezett
oldatot, hogy éppenséggel utána tovább
üdögeljék az irodai székembe, hanem
utána emelék és ezt fizikailag úgymond
kihajtom magamból. Ö szerintem
energiaitaloknak
a rendszeres fogyasztása az mindenképpen
kockázatot jelent. meg valamit
kompenzálunk is vele, tehát hogy
időnként lehet, hogy szükségünk van egy
valamilyen löketre ilyen-olyan okoknál
fogva, de hogyha folyamatosan
fogyasszuk, az mintogyha valami
kompenzáljuk az ére a az életmódunknak a
hegytelen mivoltját, mi voltát
szükségünk van nagyon gyakran ilyen,
akkor légy
>> nagyon sok a rossz minőségű alvásokat
próbálják kávéval vagy energiaitallal
pótolni, de ez nem nem lehet
helyettesíteni egy rossz minőségalvást,
sőt el kell szomorítsak mindenkit, hogy
nem is lehet bepótolni. Tehát a kimaradt
éjszakákat vagy a
>> azzal megöregedtünk, tehát azzal a
annyival megöregettük.
>> A kimaradt éjszakákat, vagy a rossz
minőségű avvásokat, ezeket nagyon nagyon
nagyon nehéz ezeket helyettesíteni vagy
bepótolni. És itt az egyik legnagyobb
problémának azt látom, aki aki nagyon
rendszertelenül végzi ezt a folyamatot,
vagy az élet módjának köszönhetően
gondoljunk például egy egyetemistára.
Ott nagyon sokszor azt látjuk ugye, hogy
megvannak a amennyire rendszerett hét
rendszerezett hétköznapok, hétfőtől
péntekig be kell járni, órákra,
kurzusokra kell járni, satöbbi, satöbbi.
És akkor ahogy eljött a péntek este,
akkor onnantól felborul minden egészen
vasárnapigi. Tehát ilyen nem egységes,
ez felzavar. Egy másik nagy kockázat
tényezőt látok azokban a munkás
emberekben, akik több váltásban
dolgoznak. Tipikus orvosi, kórházi
munkások például. Én sajnálom.
>> Nem lehet hozzászokni amúgy ehhez.
>> Nem lehet hozzászokni ehhez. Ez hosszú
távon mindenképpen kihatással van.
Hormonháztartásra, hormonrendszerre
egyértelműen,
alvásminőségre is. Így ezáltal ez egész
az egész energiaszintünkre,
ingerküszöbünkre, mindenre. De amit amit
mindenképpen kiemelkedő fontosságnak
tartok, az, hogy hosszú évek, évtiztiek
alatt az, hogy egyik héten lehet, hogy
nappal aludt, a másik héten meg éjszaka
alszik, másik héten meg lehet délután.
Tehát ez a ez a folyamatos
össze-visszaság olyan negatív hatással
lesz az ő saját belső biológiai órájára,
a cirk ritmusára, ami hormonálisan
biztos, hogy érezhető lesz néhány év
alatt.
>> Hm.
És még emgetem, mert mert édesapám
például így dolgozott egy életen
keresztül, hogy mindenféle ilyen három
három váltásban.
Jó.
Még lenne egy terület, ami nagyon
érdekelne. Ez az étrendkiegészítőknek a
területe.
Körülbelül egy pár hónappal ezelőtt
nyáron eldöntöttem egy pár dolgot. Az
egyik az, hogy én tipikusan egy ilyen
intellektuális munkát végző személy
vagyok, kép előtt ülök, megpróbálok
nagyon sok mindent megtenni azért, hogy
éber tudjak lenni, fókuszált tudjak
lenni, mert ez ez befolyásol mindent, a
céges sikert, a családomnál, mennyire
tudok ott lenni a családomnál fejbe,
mennyire tudok ott lenni a gyerekekkel.
És az egyik dolog, amit rákerestem az
interneten, hogy mi az, ami viszont a
fókusz segíti az agyi működéseket, én
kaptam három ételkiegészítőt, és ott a
ott is az volt az alapelvem, hogy legyen
olcsó, mert hogyha drága, mármint, hogy
önmagában az alapanyag drága, nem a leg
tehát hogy megfizethető legyen. Nem
akarok valamilyen elit snob életet élni,
ahol olyan étrendkiegészítőket eszek
meg, amit az átlag ember nem tud
megengedni. Van pár alacsonyaban függő
gyümölcsvis viszont, amit láttam, hogy
hát ez igazából pár 10 lej per hónap.
Nem, nem túl drága. És van itt három, de
írnék egy listát arról, amit még ezen
felül még javasolnál. Plusz erre a
háromra is nem bánnám, ha reflektálnál,
hogy mi a véleményed. Ez az első ez a a
kreatin, a kreatin monohidrát,
>> a második ez a a lecitin, és a harmadik
pedig a az omega-3.
>> Ühüm.
Reflektálj akkor erre a háromra, és
utána még jegyzetelek, hogy miket
javasolnál, ami tényleg olcsó. Tehát nem
egy ilyen elit pár százjes havonta
kiadás, hanem mondjuk úgy, hogy férjünk
bele, vagy mondjuk Euróba, mert sok
magyarországi néző is van, pár maximum
10 eurós nagyságrendben, tehát hogy hogy
nem akarok egy drága dolgot.
Jó, ezt azért nem tudom így
általánosítani a maga a termék árát,
mert nagyon függ maga a gyártó, hogy
milyen minőséget vesz, és nem maga csak
az alapanyag fogja meghatározni a
termékárát, hanem az, hogy az milyen
gyártási körülmények között gyártódott.
esetleg ezt ezek érzékenyek
elfogyaszthatják, garantál egy gyártó
azt, hogy nincsen benne
keresztszennyeződés, mondjuk egy
gluténérzékeny, egy szöliákiás is
beveheti-e, vagy olyan üzemben készül,
ahol ezt nem garantálják, és lehet, hogy
azon a gyártósoron szennyeződhetett
egyéb hatóanyaggal, egyéb nem kívánatos
hatóanyaggal. Tehát ezt így ez ezért
nehéz, de menjünk bele a hatóanyagokba.
Kreatív monohidrát.
Érdekességképpen mondom el azt, hogy a
világpiacon az összes étrendkiegészítő
közül a legjobban kutatott
étrendkiegészítő. Semmilyen
étrendkiegészítővel nem végeztek annyi
kutatást, mint a kreatív monohidráttal.
És még egy fontos tény, tonnába mérve a
világpiacon a kreatív monohidrát a
legeladottabbendkiegészítő
a világpiacon köszönhető leginkább a
sport felhasználási céljának. Te most
nem ne nem innen közelítetted meg a
témát, te egy teljesen más területre
szeretnéd.
Maga a kreatin vagy kreatív monohidrát,
azt leszögezném már most, hogy étrend
kiegészítőként nem csak a kreatív
monohidrát formája kapható.
Több formája is, mint például trikreatin
malát, kreatin hidroklorid,
kreatív foszfát formák satöbbik
elérhetőek. egyéni toleranciák jel
jelentenek különbséget, hogy ki mit
emész jól, kinek melyik forma, nem okoz
puffadást, nem okoz has hasfájást és
esetleg hasmenést is, de
általános javaslat szerint a monohidrát
a legbiztonságosabb, a legtöbbet
kutatott és ezzel érdemes kezdeni a
pótlást, ha valaki szeretné elkezdeni a
kreatinnak a a kiegészítését. Teljesen
természetes vegyületről beszélünk, ami
azt jelenti, hogy bizonyos húsokban,
főleg vörös húsokban, illetve halakban
felelhető három aminósból álló vegyület,
ami teljesen természetes,
nem bírja a hőt, ez egy nagyon fontos
dolog, tehát ami azt jelenti, hogy ezért
a húsokban és a halakban felelhető
mennyiség erőteljes hőkezelés hatására
csökkenhet, és ugyanígy az
étrendkiegészítőként történő bevételet
bevételét is melegfolyadékba kever nem
javasoljuk, mert gyakorlatilag
tönkremehet, tehát egy hőérzékeny
hatóanyagról van szó.
>> Tehát gyakorlatilag egy flekken, amit
megsütnek, abból kív nem sok marad.
Abból nem sok marad. Igen.
>> Marha hús talán a legkiemelkedőbb
forrása lenne. Tehát egy
>> az egy drága dolog és egy azért mondtam,
hogy marha hús, jó vörös hús, sok benne
a kreatin. És nagyon sokan úgy
fogyasszták, hogy nincsen teljesen
ássütvé. Tehát egy steak formájában, egy
médiumra elkezdett stake formájában,
abban több lesz a kreatint tartalom is.
Nagyon sokan a kreatint azt sportcéllal
kezdik el használni, és innen ismerik,
javítsa a teljesítményt, tehát jobb lesz
az izomregeneráció,
adenozin trifoszfát szint, tehát az ATP
szintet jelentősen fokozza, és ezáltal
rövidtávú, robbanékony edzéseknél a
teljesítmény az mérhetően jobb lesz már
néhány hét használat után. azért kell a
néhány hét használat, mert a kreatin az
az izomban tárolódik, és ez úgymond fel
kell teljen a szervezet vele. Tehát
hogyha valaki elkezd egy standardózist
használni, ami átlagfelhasználó számára
3 kötő 5 g-os mennyiség, akkor
körülbelül akár négy-6 hét is szükséges
ahhoz, hogy elérjük ezt a feltöltést,
teljes feltöltődést, és akkor
jelentkeznek a igazi pozitív változások.
viszont szokták alkalmazni ezt a kreatin
töltési fázist, amivel egy hétig mondjuk
emelt 5-től hét napig akár 10 napig
emeldózist használnak. Ez lehet 15 g, 20
g, 30 g. Ez testsúlyfüggő igazából. És
attól is függ, hogy kinek az
emésztőrendszere hogyan tolerálja, tehát
ne okozzon ez ha panaszokat,
diszkomfortot, puffadást, hasmenést.
Feltöltsük vele a szervezetünket, és
akkor utána visszatérünk egy szinten
tartó mennyiségre.
A legtöbb kutatást, ahogy mondtam, ezzel
végezték az étrendkészítő piacon, és a
legtöbb kutatásban ezt a átlagembereknél
ezt a 3-5 got használták. Ez működött.
És az az érdekes, hogy ezt a 3-5 gos
mennyiséget nemcsak fizikai
teljesítményre vették észre, hogy
működik, hanem az agyi agyifunkciókat,
kognitív funkciókat jelentősen
javította.
De viszont olyan kutatások is jelentek
meg a kreatívinnal kapcsolatosan, ami
Parkinson és Alzheimer kóros betegeknél
is javította az állapoton, tehát hogy
már itt is érdemes lenne. Még egy
érdekesség a kreatinnal az, hogy idős
korban nagyon-nagyon jó kiegészítő
lehet, főleg egy ilyen 50-60 éves
korosztály után, mivel hogy segíti
megőrizni az izomtömeget, illetve az
erőt, és nagyon sokszor ebben a korban
csökken az erőszint, elgyengülnek a az
illetők, és ez a kreatin használata,
rendszeres bevitele segít megőrizni az
erőszintet, elhúzza az izomveszteségnek
a tehát a a maga periódusát, később
veszítik el az emberek az izomtömeget,
később gyengülnek el, és ez egy
nagyon-nagyon fontos.
>> Vissza lehet nyerni amúgy az imam
tömeget, te fel ott van az 50-es évei
közepén valaki és azon gondolkozik, hogy
elég rossz bőrben vagyok. Vissza lehet
nyerni? Sosem késő elkezdeni. A
szervezet mindig fog reagálni rá. Már
nem egy 20 éves szervezet nem olyan
állapotban van sem az izomrendszer, sem
az idegrendszer, sem a csontrendszer,
sem az emésztőrendszer, és hormonálisan
sincsen abban a nincsen az ereje
tejében, úgymond, de viszont mindig
reagál a szervezet rá. Tehát nagyon
sokszor látunk akár a közösségi médiában
is olyan átalakulásokat, amikor 60-70
évesen kezdenek bele egy
aktívabb életet élni, egy egészségesebb
életet élni. Odafélnek a táplálkozásukra
és beiktatik beiktatják a rendszeres
testmozgásukat célzottan, ami azt
jelenti, hogy rezisztencia jellegű
terhalés kell ahhoz, hogy az izomtömeget
növeljük. Tehát például te említetted,
hogy rendszeresen futtál, vagy futsz,
nem tudom, a mai napig, azzal nem fogsz
tudni izomtömeget növelni. Ahhoz, hogy
izomtömeget növeljünk vagy fenntartsunk,
oda rezisztencia jellegű terhelés kell,
ami azt jelenti, hogy például az is elég
már, amit említettem én irodai
dolgozóknak, hogy TRX kötéllel
rezisztenciát, tehát ellenállásos edzést
végezzünk, de lehet ez egy súlyzó, lehet
ez egy gumkötél, lehet ez egy valamilyen
szalag. Igazából a lényeg az, hogy az
izomzatra terheléses ellenállást kell
gyakorolni, aminek következtében
mikrérülések keletkeznek, és ettől az
regenerálódik, ettől erősebb lesz.
fenntartsa a tömegét, esetleg növekszik
az izomtömeg. kérdésre válaszolva 60-70
évesen is elérhető az, hogy az
izomtömeget ment, fenntartsuk vagy akár
növeljük is. De nem csak az edzésen
múlik, hanem itt nagyon fontos tényezni,
hogy a táplálékbevitel,
tehát az, hogy ki mennyi fehérjét
fogyasz, például mekkora kalóbevitel,
illetve maga a regenerációs fázisoknak a
kimaximalizálása. Tehát itt gondolok
például az alvásra, edzés utáni
pihenésekre satöbbi. Omega-3
>> Omega-3
Én úgy tartom, hogy az összes termék
közül, ami a piacon kapható, étrend
kiegészítőként a legveszélyesebb
étrendkiegészítő.
>> Máris kihúztam.
>> Igen, figyelek. Miért?
>> Több okból. Az egyik az, hogy tehát
omega 3 készítményeket igazából
kettő főforrás van, amiből készítenek.
Az egyik azok a tipikusan a halol
oolajak, a másik pedig a növényi lehet
omega3 kiegészítők, a vegánok például
azokat különböző algák kivonatából
készítik. Mindkettő esetében az van,
hogy egy tengeri óceáni dologról
beszélünk, ami nagyon sokszor
szennyezett lehet különböző nehéz
fémekkel, ólommal, hignyal satöbbi. Ezek
sajnos nagyon sok étrendkiegészítő, meg
a három készítményebben is kimutathatóak
voltak.
Ettől szemben, ami szerintem sokkal
nagyobb probléma az, hogy az
értelentkieztő piacon nincsen
szabályozva az, hogy az omega3 terméken
fel kell-e tüntetni azt, hogy milyen
formában van benne az omega-3, mint
zsírsav.
Két fő formáját alkalmazzák két
rendkerésztőkben. Az egyik az az
etiléster, a másik pedig a trilicerit
forma. Mit kell erről tudni? Az
etiléster az egy szintetikusabb
változata. Hasonlóképpen megfog szoktam
megfogalmazni,
hogy az hogy az átlagfelhasználó is
megértse, mint az olívaolaj esetén. Van
az extra szűz és van az, ami ott maradt
benne, amiket már különböző egyéb kémiai
módszerekkel is vonnak ki. Ugye az extra
szűz az csak egy hideg préselés. Ühüm.
>> Az olol esetén még a maradvány az egy
kémiai processzálás, amiben már nem
lehet tudni, hogy mennyi az a jótékony
dolog, ami polifenolok satöbbik, amik
benne vannak a hidegpréselésű
extravallajban.
illetve, hogy az a kémiai
vegyszerhasználat az milyen egészségügyi
kockázatokat rejtő magában. Ugyanez van
jelen esetben az omega-3 piacon is, hogy
létezik a TG változat, az a triglicerid
változat a halolajakban, ami a
természetes formája. És létezik az
etiler verzió, ami a szintetikusabb
verziója az omega-3 kiegészítőknek.
Jelentős probléma az, hogy ezt nem
kötelező a termékcímkén feltüntetni.
Vagy drágább is az, amelyik
>> sokkal drágább az a hatóanyag. Igen.
>> Nem kötelező feltüntetni. Emellett még
fogok mondani dolgokat, amik amik
problémásak lehetnek egy egy halolaj
készítmény esetén, az az avasodása az
olajnak. Ezt totox érték, Totox skálán
mérik. Ez sem kötelező feltüntetni a
termékek címkején. Tehát ha egy gyártó
feltünteti azt, hogy az adott termékben,
amit megvásárolunk tőle jó pénzért, ott
milyen a Totox érték, ő arra büszke. Nem
azért tünteti fel, mert egy nagyon rossz
értéket produkál, hanem azért tünteti
fel, merthogy jó adnak a Totox értéke,
jó, jó, jó, nem a nem Így van. Nehéz jó
értéket produkálni,
>> ne ért
>> könnyen a vasodik és azonnal fel kell
dolgozni ezeket a présert halolaj
készítményeket.
Ez az egyik. A másik, ezeket kell
stabilizálni valamilyen
antioxidánsokkal, főleg az olajak
esetében, amik nincsenek bekapszulázva,
hogy ne oxidálódjon, mert elkezd
zavasodni. És itt
>> tehát hogyha veszünk, akkor kapszula az
a legjobb a
>> nem mondom, hogy az a legjobb, mert az
olajakat is olyan jól például
E-vitaminnal olyan jól le tudják a
zsíroldékony nagyon jól le tudják
stabilizálni, hogy ne oxidálódjon, vagy
kevésbé oxidálódjon. sötét üvegben
vannak, ez a fénytől védi őket, illetve
hogyha hogyha felbontás után hűvös
helyen tárolandó, tehát például egy
hűtőszekrényben, akkor az szintén tudja
nagyon sokáig védeni. Totox érdékekre
érdemes nagyon figyelni, nem tudjuk mi
megmérni saját magunknak, főleg egy
kapszulázott érték esetén, hogy mekkora
a totox érték valóban, de hogyha egy
gyártófej tünteti azt, akkor ő azért
tünteti fel, mert ő erre büszke. És
hogyha a a tudatos vásárlónak tünteti
fel, aki olyan terméket keres, hogy
tudja, hogy miért ezt kell megvenyem,
mert tudom, hogy ennek a Totox értéke
mondjuk öt alatti, ami egy nagyon jó
értéknek számít az étrend készítő
piacon.
Ha valamelyik gyártó feltünteti azt,
hogy ebbe triglicerid van, ő ezt azért
tünteti fel, mert erre ő büszke, mert
megint a tudatos vásárló tudni fogja
azt, hogy a trilcerid típus omega 3 az
igazi, és azt tudjuk mi nagyon-nagyon
jól hasznosítani, és az számunkra a
legjobb verzió és nem káros, míg az
etilésert
valamennyire
>> tudjuk hasznosítani,
>> közel nem hasznosul olyan formában.
viszont mondok egy otthoni tesztet,
hogyha valakinek van otthon omega 3
készítménye, vagy vásárol egy olyan
készítményt, amelyiken a gyártó nem
tünteti fel, hogy ez triglicerid
változatban van, akkor hogyan lehet ezt
letesztelni otthon? Nagyon egyszerű
iporkateszt.
Kell venni egy darab iporkát, amibe be
volt csomagolva televízió, hűtőszekrény,
bármi védőként kell csinálni egy kis
lyukacskát rá, egy ilyen kis krátert, és
ki kell pukkasztani egy omega3
készítményt, amelyik van nekünk otthon,
és az olajat be kell tölteni ebbe a kis
krátérbe. Ha elkezdi az omega
zsírsavakról beszélünk, omega3
zsírsavakról, az omega-3 zsírsav elkezdi
marni vagy oldani ezt az iporkát, akkor
etiléster biztosan. Ha meg nem bántja és
ott marad, és nem nincsen ilyen
oldásszerű hang meg sistergés és
látszik, hogy az iporka nem törik el,
>> akkor akkor a trade szerint változatról
beszélünk, ami a jó és ami a természetes
formája. Lehet esetleg kontrollt
csinálni az iporkán sima acetonnal. Az
aceton az nagyon oldja a az iporkát,
úgyhogy magyarországi mondom el, hogy az
iporka az nálunk a hungaroccel. Igen,
igen, igen.
>> Úgyhogy így lehet, de visszatérve az
jótékony effektekhez, tehát ha valaki jó
verzióban pótolja, csak itt most eddig
arról beszéltem, hogy miért veszélyes a
az omega 3 étrend készítés, egy
csodálatos dolog, rengeteg jótékony
hatása van.
Szívé rendszerre nézve egyik fő
kiemelkedő tényező, de viszont az agyra
is, és az agyunk az egyik legnagyobb
omegár tartalékunk. Nekünk ühüm
>> vannak is olyan ö kimutatások,
hogy az anyatejben, amikor egy anya
kezdi szoptatni a kicsitét, akkor
viszonylag van benne omega-3, és nem is
kevés. Azért kell neki, mert az omega-3
kell az idegrendszernek, kell az ő kis
agyának a fejlődéséhez. És az agya
mármint az anya adja át, tehát tej
formájában adja át a tápanyagot a a a
kis csecsemőnek. De ha neki nincsen
étrendi bevitele, vagy étrendkiegésztő
bevitele, hát akkor a saját tartalékait
fogja átadni. Szoptatás végére, ami egy
hosszabb periódus, egy év, két év is
lehet, ugye egy szoptatás periódus.
annak az anyának, akinek nem volt
étrendi omega-3 pótlása, vagy
étrendkiegészítő pótlása, az agy
térfogata 2-3%-kal csökkenhet, merthogy
a legnagyobb omega-3 tartalékunk az az
agyunkban van, és átadja gyakorlatilag
az omega-3 tartalékából, hogy ez hosszú
távon tud-e rendeződni, leáll a
periódus, vége van a szopizásnak és az
anya étrendő, pótolója satöbbi. Ezekkel
kapcsolatos információm nincsen, de ez
egy megdöbbentő és nagyon durva adat,
hogy az anya átadja a kicsi számára az ő
saját tartalékát, aminek a nagy része
többek között az agyban van.
Sajnos az időnk lejárt, de még addig nem
foglak elengedni, ameddig
bár dob fel azokat a a egyrészt most
étrendkiegészítés
terén azokat a kiegészítőket, amiket még
javasolnál emellett csak így
címszavakban, mert hogyha belemegyünk a
részletekbe, az 5-10 perceket fogja
vinni, és lehet, hogy majd még egyszer
le fogunk ülni beszélgetni külön
ezekről, de hogy érdekelne, mit minek
nézzek utána? Van-e még a fejedbe valami
olyan, ami amit javasolnál kifejezetten
fókuszra és agyvékenységre?
>> Igen. Te már említetted a lecitint, azt
két szóban elmondom, hogy miért fontos.
A lecitinnek van egy van egy
kin forrása, a kin tartalma, és a kin az
egy nagyon-nagyon fontos az acetil colin
szintéziséhez, ami az egyik legfontosabb
neurotranszmitter a tanuláshoz, a
memóriához,
a fókuszhoz. És hogyha több acetilkolint
termelünk mi, akkor ezek a folyamatok
tudnak javulni. Tehát ezért is fontos
lehet a lecitinnek a bevitele. Itt
esetleg arra lehet érdemes figyelni,
hogy a lecitin miből származik. Legtöbb
termékben mondjuk szója lecitint
használnak, de létezik
napraforgólecitin, meg repitin is a
piacon. Úgyhogy kinek melyik a
szimpatikusabb, van-e valami
ellenjavallat a szójával kapcsolatosan,
vagy nincsen, vagy másra, vagy számára
allergiás reakciót okozhat-e, vagy nem?
Úgyhogy ezekre érdemes figyelni.
létezik olyan standardizált kivonalat,
amin kivonata a lecitinnek, amelyik
standardizálva direktbe
foszfatidilkolint vagy foszfatidil
szerint tartalmaz nagyon mennyiségben.
Ezek általában még jobban működnek, de
mivel ez is a kin bevitelen keresztül
javítja az acetilkolin termelőését, és
ez egy nagyon nagyon nagyon fontos
neurotranszmitterként működik, az
étrendi kollinbevitel is tud segíteni.
legjobb forrása a máj, tehát az állatok
mája, a tojás sárgája, illetve a kaviár.
Ezt a hármat emelném ki, amik
nagyon-nagyon jó kólinbevitel
lehetőségek.
étrendkiegészítő kapként kapható még, és
akkor most belete az új termékekbe, a
Citicolin nevű hatóanyag, ami aminek
étrendi forrásáról én nem tudok, de
viszont ez a City Colorin, ez legjobban
hasznosodó Corinforrás, tehát még jobb
lesz az acatil Colin szintézis, és
ezáltal neurotranszmitterként működik,
és jobb lesz a fókusz memórija és a
tanulási képességünk.
Mondok néhány olyan hatóanyagot, amik az
agyi mikrokeringésre vannak jó hatással,
és ezáltal jobb mikrokeringés, jobb vér
és tápanyagellátás. Ilyen például a
Jinobiloba, mint hatóanyag,
növényi kivonat. Általában az ilyen
növényi hatanyagnál fontos tényező
szokott az lenni, hogy ne maga a növényt
vegyük meg, tehát ne arra figyeljünk,
hogy a gyártó azt garantálja, hogy jó
sok van benne, hanem annak a
standardizált kivonatát annak a annak a
növénynek lesz egy hatóanyaga, vagy két
hatóanyaga, amire amire standardizálták
a kivonatot, és hogy az mit mond a
gyártó, hogy az hány százalék, vagy hány
milligram. Hiába írja rá, hogy 500 mg
van a kapszulában maga a növényből, ha
az éppen csak 2% hatonatal. Lehet jobban
járunk egy olyannal, amelyik az,
amelyikre az van ráírva, hogy csak 200
mg van benne, de ez 10% ható
tartalommal. Ezekre ezek ezekre fontos
igazából odafigyelni.
Bakopa monieri kivonat kifejezetten
memóriára
nagyon-nagyon jó növényű.
Bakopa, Monieri
>> Monieri.
>> Igen,
>> igen.
>> Szint ez kifejezetten memóriát tudja
javítani. Gotuko lakivonat, ami szintén
hasonlóan a
ginko bilobához szintén a
>> sajnos nem lesz időknem mikrokeringést
javít. Úgyhogy még egy párat mondjál
csak azért, hogy utánanézzek és ez egy
jó teszt is lesz, hogy a hallgatókat ha
érdekli, akkor belemegyünk ebbe
különböző ginzeng családok, ide itt
megemlíteném a Panax Ginzenget például
viszont az indiai ginzenget, ami
ismertebb nevén az asvaganda kivonat
vagy állombogyó kivonat, az nem
konkrétan kifejezetten a memóriát vagy
agyifunkciókat javítsa, de a
stresszkezelésnek
át indirekt módon jó hatása van a
fókuszra, meg a tanulás képesség ekre
is.
>> Ühüm.
>> Talán ezek lennének a legfontosabbak,
amiket mindenképpen kiemelnék, és amit
már mondtam, hogy növények esetén
fontos, hogy standardizált
hatótartalomról beszélünk.
>> Szuper volt ez a beszélgetés. Én nagyon
hálás vagyok, hogy leültünk. körülbelül
a kétharmadát át tudtuk venni annak,
amit szerettem volna, de hogy a célja
tényleg az volt, hogy ez a sok apró
tanács, ez a sok apró dolog, ami amit az
emberiség kollektívan kikisérletezhet
saját magán, ezek összeadódnak és
összeszorzódnak. És az az ember, aki
eddig úgy sodródott, úgy nem nagyon
gondolt bele a a mindennapjaiba, és így
a hétköznapjait élve, azon veszi észre
magát, hogy alacsony az energiaszintje
is kez kihalt mindenre. Én azt tudom
tanácsolni, hogy egyenként ezeket
próbálja meg bevezetni az életébe
rutinszerűen. Úgy úgy, hogy már el is
feledkezik róla, hogy hogy csinálja, és
javítson a az alvási minőségén, javítson
az étrendjén, a mozgásán, javítson az a
a légzésén.
>> Szóval rengeteg mindenről beszélgettünk
és és köszönöm, [zene] hogy itt voltál,
hogy ezeket köszönöm a lehetőséget
>> és várunk vissza a stúdióba. Köszönöm
szépen. [zene] Legyen így.